Dann legen wir los. Ah ne, Moment, ich muss ja den Code Opener machen. Sekunde, vielleicht jetzt. Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Männerfußball und wir schauen damit mit Nils Kern auf La Liga, mit Christian Bernhard auf die Serie A, mit Uli Hebel auf die Premier League, mit Daniel Zander auf die Eredivisie und mit Jakob Haffke auf die Liga. Da soll noch einer sagen, hier werden nicht alle Ligen abgedeckt. Und nein, kein Portugal. Meldet euch einfach nicht. Jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, gleich mal mit ein bisschen Rage-Bate angefangen. Super League gibt es hier übrigens auch nicht. Vielleicht könnte ich ja so, vielleicht sollte ich das wirklich mal machen, was es hier alles nicht gibt. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr die Ligatour hört, obwohl wir es leider nicht schaffen, den kompletten Weltfußball abzudecken. Ich weiß, ich ärgere mich ja auch ein bisschen drüber. Aber ich freue mich sehr über meine Runde. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Ich begrüße euch. Grüß dich, meine Hörerinnen und Hörer. Fein, liebe Leute. Wir starten gleich rein, weil viele Gäste bedeutet auch viele Themen. Christian, du beginnst. Wir blicken mal nach Italien und wir müssen über Juve sprechen. Was war da los zuletzt?
Ja, viel. Ich glaube, wir müssen mal bei den letzten Tagen anfangen. Juve hat in der Champions League, ist bei Galatasaray richtig schön baden gegangen. Hat drei Tage davor ein sehr emotionales Derby d'Italia gegen Inter verloren in der 90. Ich glaube, da lohnt jetzt ein Blick drauf, weil er hat jetzt glaube ich in der letzten Folge ja schon mal angerissen. Also das Ballett hat da viel Gutes auf den Weg gebracht. Aber man hat jetzt doch auch gemerkt, gerade das Galatasaray-Spiel, dass sie halt doch noch anfällig, irgendwie auch ein bisschen naiv manchmal sind. Also kurz Recap, Juve führt in Istanbul 2-1 zur Halbzeit und ja geht dann am Ende. Kabal bekommt Gelb-Rot eingewechselt zur zweiten Hälfte, fliegt dann schnell mit Gelb-Rot und kassieren dann halt noch vier Dinger verlieren, 5-2, was jetzt ja würde ich mal sagen das Weiterkommen äußerst, äußerst, äußerst schwierig macht. Bei Galatasaray auswärts zu verlieren, glaube ich, ich glaube wir wissen alle, wie schwierig es ist auswärts bei Galatasaray zu spielen. Also das ist jetzt nicht der Punkt, aber dann logisch fünf Kisten zu bekommen und halt auch so ein bisschen auseinander zu fallen. Und da hat man so ein bisschen die, ja wie soll man sagen, die Vulnerabilität von Juve halt noch gemerkt. Bremer musste in der ersten Halbzeit verletzt raus und dann war Kelly auch teilweise Vogelwild, weil ohne Bremer verliert auch Kelly an Stabilität. Dann kommt Kabal eben rein, lässt sich mit Gelb-Rot vom Platz stellen und dann geht es dahin. Also einiges Gutes, was bei Juve in den letzten Wochen definitiv auf den Weg gebracht wurde, merkt man halt doch eben, dass es fragil ist sozusagen noch. Und dann müssen wir schon eben auf drei Tage zuvor auch noch zurück, weil im San Siro war das Derby d'Italia und da hat sich Juve sehr, sehr gut spielerisch präsentiert. Gerade erste Halbzeit haben sie nicht nur mitgespielt mit Inter, sondern auch richtig gut Druck auf Inter gemacht. Und dann gab es eine richtig, richtig heiß diskutierte Schiedsrichterentscheidung, denn kurz vor der ersten Halbzeit fliegt Kalulu mit gelb-rot. Dadurch ist logisch das komplette Spiel anders geworden. Ja, und er fliegt, weil davor Bastoni eigentlich geflogen ist. Also es gab einen leichten Kontakt. Kalulu an Bastoni leicht an der Hand. Bastoni fliegt heftig. Kalulu war schon gelb vorbelastet. Ja, dann wird er eben vom Schiri runtergeschickt. Und das Problem, deswegen wollte ich es auch mitbringen, ich bin eigentlich kein Freund davon, immer einzelne Szenen zu thematisieren. Aber das hat jetzt eine Riesendiskussion in Italien ausgelöst. Denn es war eine Fehlentscheidung, aber das Problem war eben das VAR-Protokoll, nämlich bei gelb-rot darf der VAR ja nicht rein. Und dadurch, dass es jetzt bei so einem wichtigen, großen Spiel in Italien, ich meine das Derby in Italien, da schauen halt einfach alle drauf, war das jetzt einfach tagelang ein Riesenthema. Und ich bin mal gespannt, ob da wirklich Richtung neue Saison auch ein bisschen Dynamik reinkommt. Denn ich bin auch der Meinung, ja, ich weiß, jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich welche jetzt sagen, ja, aber wenn wir die zweite Gelbe anschauen, dann müsste man ja vielleicht die erste Gelbe auch anschauen. Ja, aber ich bin trotzdem auf der anderen Seite, denn Platzverweis ist Platzverweis, egal ob rot oder gelb-rot, das ändert halt die Dynamik eines Spiels komplett. Und das war wirklich ein wunderbares Beispiel, weil Juve war komplett auf Augenhöhe, erste Halbzeit hat richtig gut mitgespielt. Und dann, zweite Hälfte logischerweise, mussten sie sich nur noch hinten tief verteidigen. Und am Ende gewinnt das Inter 3-2, obwohl Juve noch mal in Unterzahl auch noch ausgeglichen hat. Und deswegen, ja, bin ich sehr gespannt. Also in Italien kommt jetzt auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr, sehr viel frischer Wind oder aus Italien in dieses VAR-Protokoll, wenn es darum geht, bei Gelb-Rot womöglich doch vielleicht besser draufzuschauen.
Das ist ja sogar schon in den Vorschlägen ans IFAB mit drin, dass eben eine zweite gelbe Karte überprüft wird. Und man kann es ja auch so verargumentieren, selbst wenn die erste gelbe Karte unberechtigt war, weiß der Spieler, dass er schon gelb vorbelastet ist und geht dann entsprechend in, in Duelle. Und was ja dann diese Szene noch mal so besonders macht, ist, dass Pastoni ja auch schon gelb vorbelastet war. Also wenn es quasi eigentlich richtig entschieden worden wäre, hätte er Gelb-Rot gesehen und nicht Kaluli.
Definitiv. Genau, ja. Also war wirklich auch sehr emotional die letzten Tage auf Pastoni. Der hat jetzt auch vor dem Champions-League-Spiel, saß sich dann auch in die Pressekonferenz rein, weil er musste sich dazu äußern. Also die Tage waren wirklich extrem heiß in Italien. Pastoni hat einen Fehler gemacht, hat es auch eingestanden, hat gemeint, ja, keine Frage, das hätte so nicht sein sollen von meiner Seite. Hat aber halt auch drum gebeten, weil muss man schon dazu sagen, Pastoni ist jetzt nicht dafür bekannt oder hat keine Vorgeschichte, da ganz schlimme Sachen auf dem Feld zu veranstalten. Hat halt gemeint, muss mir vielleicht auch mal zugestanden sein, einen Fehler zu machen. Denn das Problem war logisch, das muss ich euch jetzt nicht erklären. Logisch, auf Social Media war die letzten Tage die Hölle los. Da wurden auch teilweise seine Frau, seine Kinder, wurden damit reingezogen. Das war halt wieder mal dieses sehr, sehr unschöne Beispiel, dass aus so einer heiß diskutierten Szene logischerweise dann Auswüchse entstehen, ja, die logischerweise völlig fehl am Platz sind. Aber ja, es war wirklich, also diese Szene wird die Serie A noch lange beschäftigen, denn in der Halbzeit kam es schon zu richtigen Tumulten unten in den Katakomben. Chiellini und Cummoli wurden jetzt auch gesperrt. Spalletti ist auch richtig ausgestiegen. Also es war marot, dass Spalletti gab es danach auch noch heftige Diskussionen. Es sind viele Pfeile hin und her geschossen worden. Ich meine, Inter Juve, muss ich euch nicht sagen, Riesenrivalität über Jahre, Jahrzehnte. Und ja, vielleicht ist wirklich unter Anführungszeichen das einzige Gute an der Szene, dass jetzt da wirklich dadurch, dass es in so einem großen Spiel passiert ist, auch in einem großen europäischen Spiel, da, glaube ich, was diese Gelb-Rot-Entscheidungen und VAR betrifft, Dynamik reingekommen ist, ganz klar.
Und dann, wir müssen jetzt nicht nochmal ins Detail reingehen, weil wir haben ja schon zuletzt über Juve gesprochen in der letzten Sendung. Aber kurze Einschätzung von dir, das waren jetzt natürlich turbulente Spiele und halt auch bittere Spiele, denn das eine hinter erklärt sich von alleine. Und GALA eben, weil es jetzt zumindest sehr schwer würde, weiterzukommen, aus der Zwischenrunde raus. Darüber hinaus, wenn ich auf die Tabelle blicke, würde ich aber sagen, so viel ist nicht passiert. Man ist weiter an den Champions-League-Plätzen easy dran. Ein Punkt Rückstand, hat auch da noch direkte Duelle. Unter anderem jetzt dann nach dem GALA-Rückspiel zu Hause, ne, Entschuldigung, auswärts, bei der Roma. Also hätte ich gesagt, klar, jetzt erstmal turbulent und nicht schön. Aber Champions League immer noch easy drin. Und das wäre ja dann auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Teilerfolg.
Ja, aber das ist schon auch der Minimal-Erfolg. Also bei Juve ging es die letzten Jahre auch immer drum, wirklich auch in den Top 4 zu landen. Auch aus wirtschaftlichem Druck sozusagen. Und du hast es ja angesprochen, es ist schon sehr eng. Die Roma ist da dran. Im Moment sind es fünf Mannschaften um vier Plätze. Napoli hat sich jetzt auch ein bisschen gefangen, hat ein kleines Polster. Also es ist schon bei Juve zuletzt, also vor zwei Wochen, wenn wir da über Juve gesprochen hätten, dann wäre es sehr viel rosig gewesen, weil wirklich Spalletti viel auf den Weg gebracht hat. McKennie, sieben Tore jetzt seit Spalletti da ist, also viele gute Sachen. Aber jetzt die jüngsten Spiele, sie sind auch in der Coppa Italia ausgeschieden gegen Atalanta, sind sie auch nicht mehr im Rennen. Und eben davor gab es ein 2-2 in der Liga auch gegen Lazio. Also sie müssen schon schauen, da in diesem, ja wie soll ich sagen, in diesem engen Rennen drin zu bleiben, denn es bleibt dabei. Die wirtschaftliche Situation von Juve ist angespannt. Im Prinzip sind die auf die Champions League Millionen angewiesen. Und dementsprechend ist da Druck drauf. Aber sagen wir mal so, wenn es so läuft, wie es im Moment aussieht, nämlich dass sie sich nächste Woche im Moment halt eher wahrscheinlich als unwahrscheinlicher aus der Champions League verabschieden sollten, dann hätten sie logischerweise auch den Vorteil, wie Milan zum Beispiel dann auch nur noch die Liga zu hohe haben, also jede Woche nur noch ein Spiel. Aber ja, da ist dann schon auch Druck auf Spalletti und Kodra, weil nochmal, wie gesagt, Top 4 ist absolutes Muss. Die Italiener werden nicht den fünften Platz über das UEFA-Ranking bekommen. Da sind sie jetzt auch raus, haben sie viel zu schlecht jetzt zuletzt europäisch abgeschnitten. Also im Prinzip musst du Vierter werden. Außer die Roma sollte die Europa League gewinnen. Das wäre noch das andere Szenario. Aber ja, es ist Druck drauf. Aber es gibt schon auch, wenn man die letzten Spiele ausklammern, viel positiv. Deswegen bin ich gespannt, wie sie das abschütteln. Und deswegen wollte ich es jetzt auch bringen, weil, obwohl viel Gutes da ist von Spalletti, man merkt halt trotzdem noch, es ist halt immer noch eine relativ junge Mannschaft. Nochmal zur Erinnerung, Juve hat auch in dieser Saison den zweitjüngsten Schnitt in der ganzen Serie A. Und das sind halt viele Spieler, die vielleicht, sag ich mal, diesen großen Druck bei Juve performen zu müssen, halt vielleicht noch nicht über lange Zeit gewachsen sind. Also es gibt immer wieder gute Ausreißer, gute Leistungen, auch vieles, was Hoffnung macht. Aber ja, dann Juve in die Champions League führen zu müssen, das ist jetzt schon auch Druck auf vielen Spielern. Ja, bin ich mal gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Wir werden es im Blick behalten. Und dann lasst uns doch bei den Champions League Themen bleiben, die wir jetzt zuerst hier haben. Nils, da haben wir einen Vorfall im Spiel zwischen Benfica, natürlich Lissabon und Real Madrid zu besprechen. Vinicius Jr. erzählt, erzielt das 1 zu 0. Feiert dieses Tor auch auf, man muss es schon sagen, die ihm eigene Art schon sehr ausführlich. Das soll aber nicht rechtfertigen, was danach passiert ist. Der Benfica-Spieler Gianluca Pastiani zieht sich noch das Trikot über den Mund, was schon ein Hinweis darauf ist, er möchte nicht, dass wir an seinen Lippen ablesen können, was er sagt. Und danach sagen sowohl Vinicius Jr., der direkt reagiert, als auch unter anderem Kylian Mbappé, dass er Vinicius Jr. rassistisch beleidigt hätte. Ich denke, wir die Beleidigungen jetzt nicht wiederholen, denn wenn sie rassistisch ist, dann soll sie nicht reproduziert werden. Und logischerweise– oder was heißt logischerweise? Aber leider ist es dann auch bei solchen Fällen so, dass dann so ein He-said-She-said-Ding anfängt. Also José Mourinho unter anderem behauptet, das sei gar nicht gewesen. Und es wird jetzt so eine Täter-Opfer-Umkehr davor genommen. Wie hast du dir das Ganze verfolgt? Gibt es dazu nähere Erkenntnisse? Und wie empfindest du denn jetzt dann die Debatte rund um dieses Thema?
Ja, also hast du schon einiges angesprochen. Auch, dass Mourinho das fast ein bisschen rechtfertigt im Sinne von, warum jubelst du denn so provokant? Aber als wäre wenigstens der Erste, der irgendwie tanzt beim Jubel.
Also José Mourinho ist wirklich jemand, der immer sehr zurückhaltend und demütig war bei seinen Jubeln.
Sehr rechtmännlich immer gewesen ist ja. Also da wird genau diese leichte Täter-Opfer-Umkehr getätigt. Im Endeffekt haben wir aktuell eine Situation, wo auch viele Unwahrheiten umlaufen sind. Es geht auch gar nicht immer nur um die Situation kurz vor dem Wiederanpfiff, vor dem Wiederanstoß, wo ja da sowohl Vini Stuz als Prestiani sich gegenüber stand. Es war ja auch direkt nach dem Jubel bei dem Moment, wo dann Vini Stuz auch die gelbe Karte gesehen hat, weil er dann nochmal irgendwie sich auf seinen Rücken gedeutet hat. Da ist auch schon Prestiani zu Vini Stuz gekommen, wurde dann auch schon sehr deutlich von dem MVP weggeschubsen. Das war die Situation, wo dann auch MVP nach Appfiff sehr deutlich gesagt hat. Im Sinne von, hey, das ist jetzt nicht pauschal gegen Benfica als Club, gegen die ganzen Fans, aber es kam jetzt zu rassistischen Äußerungen. Und in der Situation war es fünfmal der Fall. Und da war ein MVP sehr klar und hat nicht gesagt, ne, es war nicht nur ein paar Mal. Es war, er hat genau fünfmal gehört, dass dieses eine Wort gefallen ist. Und das wird da schon mal öfter ein bisschen unterschlagen. Benfica hat ja auch am Tag danach ein Video geteilt, was eben kurz vor dem Wiederanschluss wieder war, wo dann Benfica erklärt, hey, hier sind gar keine Madrilenen in der Nähe. Die können gar nichts gehört haben, obwohl durchaus Kammerbinger und MVP da in der Nähe waren. Aber wie gesagt, es gab da diese 2 Situationen. Also da schon viel unwahres Tatsachen, Verdrehungen im Umlauf. Und natürlich spielen auch sowohl Prestigiani als auch Benfica jetzt so ein bisschen das missverstandene Unschuldslamm. Es heißt teilweise, dass Prestigiani nicht das Wort M-O-N-O gesagt haben soll, sondern nur M-A-N-O. Das wäre die Abkürzung für Hermano, also für Bruder. Aber warum machst du dann D, wenn du wenigstens eigentlich loben willst oder so? Also da ist sehr viel Dubiosis wieder im Umlauf. Was man natürlich schlussendlich nicht genau belegen kann, weil die Spieler ja keine Mikrofone am Rücken haben. Warum eigentlich immer noch nicht? Und deswegen ist jetzt natürlich auch die UEFA irgendwo am Zug, weil der Schiedsrichter hat ja das Spiel unterbrochen. Es gab ja die klare Geste, dass das Rassismusprotokoll wurde aktiviert. Dann stand auch zur Debatte, man könnte jetzt auch das Spiel unterbrechen, aber wie nicht, das hat gesagt, nee, wir wollen weiterspielen, wir machen es weiter. Und so würde ich jetzt nicht mal sagen, dass bei der UEFA schon ein klares Verfahren eingeleitet ist, aber es wird untersucht, ob es da wirklich klare Konsequenzen gibt, weil wie gesagt, man kann einem Prestigiani das nicht direkt nachweisen, weil es keine Tonaufnahmen gibt, es gibt die Lippen sind nicht zu sehen, aber es gibt halt Spielaussagen von einem Mbappé, von einem Vinicius und Mbappé sagt auch, da waren auch Benfica-Spieler in der Nähe. Bei der ersten Situation könnte man schon, wenn man wollen würde, drauf schließen, ja, da ist es zu rassistischen Äußerungen gekommen, mal wieder gegen Vinicius, dass der ein oder andere mit seiner Art nicht kann, dass der ein oder andere Jubel vielleicht auch mal provokant wirkt und die andere Geste, okay, dann meinetwegen normal beleidigen, aber sobald es halt diese persönliche Ebene, diese Grenze mit dem Rassismus überschreitet, ist es halt rüber. Und trotzdem haben wir beide ja total aktuell einiges mal wieder zu blocken und zu bannen auf Social Media, weil, wie gesagt, viele relativieren, ja, aber der hat ja provokant gejubelt, dann muss er auch beleidigt werden. Okay, so wird dann wieder Rassismus relativiert. Also das alte Thema, ich glaube, das haben wir hier schon leider öfter mal schon gehabt.
Ja, aber es ist halt schon erstaunlich, dass sich da so gar nichts bewegt und sich so gar nichts verändert. Also, dass immer noch Leute nicht verstehen, dass es ein Unterschied ist, ob man jemanden beleidigt oder ob man jemanden rassistisch beleidigt. Und ich will damit jetzt nicht sagen, Beleidigungen per se wären gut. Aber allein diese Unterscheidung wird ja anscheinend bei vielen jetzt schon mal nicht gemacht und damit wird das relativiert. Und dass es eigentlich nicht damit zu tun hat, wie du den Spieler persönlich findest. Ich habe auch meine Meinung dazu, wie ich das Verhalten von Vini Jr. in manchen Situationen auf dem Platz finde, aber das rechtfertigt halt allein gar nichts. Ich und ehrlicherweise bin ich ein bisschen erschrocken darüber. Also es sollte einen vielleicht nicht wundern, wenn man sich ein bisschen weiter einliest. Aber ich bin ein bisschen erschrocken über die Reaktion von Benfica. Denn es ist völlig normal in der, oder was heißt freundlich normal, aber es ist leichter nachzuvollziehen, dass man aus der Emotion heraus, direkt nach dem Spiel, auch angesichts eines sehr harten Vorwurfs, also niemand möchte als rassistisch bezeichnet werden, dass man dann vielleicht nicht in der besten Art und Weise reagiert. Das finde ich zumindest noch erklärbar. Dass man aber eben auch noch am Tag danach dann eben diese Täter-Opfer-Umkehr weiterpervertiert und letztlich ja damit sagt, der lügt. Und das ist alles ein riesiges Komplott gegen uns, worauf die Spieler auch noch sehr gerne eingehen. Das kann man bei Instagram und so weiter sehr gut nachlesen, was da quasi von den Spielern selbst dazu noch geschrieben wird, unter entsprechenden Postings von Benfica. Also dann kannst du dir halt ganz viele andere Aktionen sparen, wenn du in solchen Fällen es nicht schaffst, dich gerade zu machen. Und vielleicht wir haben gerade, ich will das nicht gleich setzen, ich will es nur in Bezug zueinander setzen. Bastoni setzt sich hin und sagt, ich habe einen Fehler gemacht. Es tut mir leid. Wie gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht so tun, als ob Schweibe und Rassismus das gleiche wären. Aber die Art und Weise, wie man mit einem Fehler umgeht, möchte ich da dran quasi nochmal verdeutlichen. Das finde ich schon krass, ehrlicherweise. Ist es ja.
Es überrascht jetzt auch nicht, dass durch dann PR-Berater und Anwälte erstmal sowohl Ben Ficke als auch der Spieler dazu gebracht werden. Wir könnten den Fehler eingestehen, wir könnten ehrlich sein, aber dann haben wir halt einen riesen Imageschaden und haben immer den Rassismusstempel. Nicht nur der Spieler, sondern auch der Club wahrscheinlich. Deswegen spielen sie jetzt die Schiene wie gesagt als Unschuldslam. Ich habe es auch nicht direkt gehört. Ich habe auch nicht die Lippen von einem Prestigian gelesen, aber so wie die Reaktionen waren, von Vinicius, von Mbappé, was Mbappé danach gesagt hat. Generell auch Prestigiani danach hat ja komplett die Farbe im Gesicht verloren, wurde auch von Mbappé auf dem Platz noch damit konfrontiert und hat auch nur so, hm, hm, hab ich nicht gesagt, oh Gott. Der wusste schon ganz genau, dass da jetzt richtig die KA am Dampfen ist. Aber ja, es ist halt möglich durch, wie gesagt, fehlende Tonaufnahmen, weil die Spieler keine Mikrofone tragen. Aber es ist halt jetzt eine besonders spannende Ebene, weil jetzt muss die UEFA, ich hab's bei mir im Livestream gesagt, die UEFA hat jetzt quasi einen Elfmeter, weil sie muss jetzt einschreiten, das Rassismusprotokoll wurde aktiviert. Jetzt ist nur die Frage, verwandelt die UEFA diesen Elfmeter, weil die Belege eigentlich klar sind, oder schießt sie irgendwie aus Versehen daneben und wir können es leider nicht genau auflösen. Deswegen keine klaren Konsequenzen. Also es ist jetzt ein spannender Fall und für all die vielen tollen No-To-Racism-Kampagnen, die sie sonst so spielen, werden sie jetzt mal da am Zug. Es ist nicht auf der Tribüne gefallen, wo man es auch nicht ganz aufdröseln kann, sondern jetzt ist es mal auf dem Spielfeld passiert, von einem jungen 20-jährigen Argentinier, der da wahrscheinlich eine sehr große Dummheit getätigt hat. Aber mal gucken, wie die Wäfer reagieren wird. Meine Erwartungen sind da natürlich sehr überschaubar, weil es gibt da keine Tonaufnahmen von. Aber wenn die Wäfer da ein bisschen schneit hätte, könnte man da mal ein wirkliches Zeichen gegen Rastismus setzen.
Ich meine, das Rückspiel ist ja schon in sechs Tagen. Wenn ich tippen müsste, würde ich sagen, nach dem Rückspiel ist erst die Untersuchung beendet und sie sperren etwa drei Spiele. Ja, das ist aber nur so mein Tipp, das wäre so ein typischer UEFA-Weg. Wir haben noch was gemacht.
Früher könnte man das nicht machen, es war jetzt so kurz, acht Tage zu stinken.
Man muss ja allen Beteiligten Zeit zur Stellungnahme geben. Also wahrscheinlich, ja. Vielleicht werden wir da auch überrascht. Aber wir wollten es hier auf jeden Fall noch mathematisieren, auch wenn ihr es sicherlich schon mitbekommen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Weil ja, ich glaube, das ist dann schon wichtig, darüber auch zu reden. Und zwar in einer, ja, vielleicht anderen Art und Weise, wie es bei Social Media bei manchen so passiert.
So ist es.
Okay, dann machen wir das Thema an der Stelle aber zu, weil ich will es jetzt gar nicht entwerten, indem ich jetzt dann auch über sportliche Rede. Wir werden noch genügend über Real sprechen und auch, wie das mit Benfica im Rückspiel läuft. Das werden wir alle mitbekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schauen wir mal noch nach Frankreich, denn auch da haben wir ein Thema mit Champions League Bezug, nämlich in einem direkten Duell trafen ja PSG und Monaco aufeinander. Lieber Jakob und du wolltest das zum anders nehmen, uns mal ein Update zu geben, wie es da gerade so läuft. Und vor allem bei PSG hat man es ja vielleicht auch mitbekommen, dass die aktuell nicht Tabellenführer sind. Lance hat sich wieder vorbeigeschoben.
Er geht ja jetzt seit Wochen hin und her in Frankreich. Immer mal wieder wechselt die Tabellenführung. Und anders als ich es im Herbst prophezeit hatte, ist ja Marseille nicht dran beteiligt, sondern es ist tatsächlich Lance, die wirklich den Rhythmus aufrechterhalten und ja echt eine beeindruckende Pace hinlegen. Also haben jetzt glaube ich zu Hause 10 Spiele in Folge gewonnen. Ja auch in der Liga fast alles gewonnen, abgesehen von der einen Niederlage gegen Olympique Marseille. Und ja, ist schon ein beeindruckender Titelkampf. Aber vor allem können wir erst mal kurz noch auf das Champions League Spiel auch zu sprechen kommen gerne. Denn ja, ich sag mal so erst mal, ich bin kein großer Fan des neuen Modus und dass es dann direkt in den Playoff Runden schon Duells zwischen Teams aus gleichen Ländern gibt, finde ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sonderlich optimal. Zumal es jetzt auch in der zweiten Ausgabe das zweite Mal ist, dass zwei französische Teams aufeinandertreffen. Also das ist natürlich aus meiner persönlichen Sicht besonders suboptimal. Im letzten Jahr waren es ja PSG und Start Brest, die gegeneinander gespielt haben, wo dann PSG ja 10 zu Null insgesamt auch gewonnen hat. Also da auch maximal unglücklich natürlich für Brest gewesen damals als Überraschungsteam schlechthin in die Playoffs eingezogen und dann darf man als Dank dafür gegen den großen Dominator aus der heimischen Liga spielen und wird dann komplett auseinander genommen. Und so war es ja jetzt tatsächlich nicht. Also es war ja ein sehr durchaus spannendes Spiel. Monaco schnell 2-0 in Führung gegangen, was durchaus auch eine kleine Vorgeschichte hat, denn auch vor Weihnachten hatte Monaco PSG schon mal geschlagen, obwohl es bei Monaco selbst auch überhaupt nicht gut läuft. Also die haben ja– ich glaube, das war die allererste Folge dieser Saison oder die zweite haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass sie die Hütte rausgeschmissen hatten. Relativ überraschend, damals auch standen sie auf Platz 5 oder Platz 6, meine ich. Und es war Platz 5, genau. Und jetzt stehen sie unter Pocognoli auf Platz 8, waren zwischenzeitlich sogar in die untere Tabellenhälfte auch abgerutscht. Also man kann nicht wirklich sagen, dass der Trainerwechsel Früchte getragen hat. Pocognoli hat in der Liga einen Punkteschnitt von 1,2, was ja für ein Team mit den Ansprüchen von Monaco wirklich scheußlich ist. Und es gibt auch relativ viel Unruhe. Es gab jetzt vor dem Spiel gegen PSG auch Fan-Proteste im Stadion mit Bannern, die sich aber nicht unbedingt gegen Pocognoli, sondern vor allem gegen den Generaldirektor Thiago Scuro richten, wo schon seit Längerem gefordert wird, dass der sich zurückzieht. Da geht es vor allem auch um die Transferpolitik und die allgemeine Kaderpolitik. Und da wurde er dann auch in mehreren Sprachen zur Demission aufgefordert. Und dann im Nachhinein die Frage, ob es jetzt etwas klarer sei, nachdem man sich zuvor nicht so wirklich gehört gefühlt hat. Es gibt natürlich auch gerne immer die Witze über Monaco, da da ja nicht sonderlich viel los ist. Man hatte jetzt auch am Dienstag das Gefühl, dass mehr Paris-Fans im Stadion waren als Monaco-Fans. Aber es gibt durchaus auch relativ treue Anhänger von Monaco. Also auch wenn es wenige sind, es gibt dann schon auch Menschen, die sich damit befassen und da dementsprechend dann auch gegen vorgehen. Aber der Unmut ist schon auch verständlich. Also natürlich ist der Kader nicht so richtig gut, aber man muss schon auch klar sagen, für die Möglichkeiten, die Monaco finanziell auch hat im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Teams in Frankreich, ist Platz 8 halt auch einfach ein absolutes No-Go. Und wenn man sich nicht für Europa qualifiziert, wäre das eine riesige Enttäuschung. Man liegt jetzt nur drei Punkte hinter den Europa League-Rängen zumindest, aber allerdings auf die Champions League sind es auch schon neun Punkte. Und angesichts der Inkonstanz, die Monaco jetzt eigentlich seit der Entlassung von Hütter zeigt, ist es schon durchaus verständlich und man kann sich nicht so wirklich vorstellen, dass sie da jetzt noch mal oben reinrücken. Ein Riesenproblem ist die Abwehr. Sie haben 34 Gegentore kassiert. Damit sind sie deutlich in der unteren Tabellenhälfte, was die Gegentore angehen. Und jetzt gegen Paris zum Beispiel konnte auch Pogonjoli, der ja eigentlich eine Dreierkette präferiert, das zumindest bei Union Saint-Gélois auch immer gespielt hat, auch da nicht drauf bauen, weil er mit Wout Fahs nur einen einzigen fitten Innenverteidiger hatte. Dann hat Jordan Thézé, der in dieser Saison schon Rechtsverteidiger im defensivem Mittelfeld musste, dann jetzt als Innenverteidiger mal spielen. Zuletzt hat auch Zachariah in der Dreierkette Innenverteidiger gespielt, den man ja auch noch aus Gladbach zum Beispiel kennt. Und ja, die Abwehr– ich weiß nicht. Und dann halt im Winter geholt Wout Fahs, ob das jetzt so der Transfer ist, der Monaco unbedingt nach vorne bringt, ausgeliehen aus der zweiten Liga von Lester.
Ich hatte den Kopf und es war weh hier mit.
Ja, also.
Also in Lester sind die Apparaten zwischenanstaltet worden, dass er endlich weg ist. Hoch, hoch überbezahlt und das ist jetzt kein Witz. Also der sieht aus wie David Luiz, aber der war auch teilweise David Luiz. Der hat in jedem Spiel einen horrenden Fehler. Genau, das kommt noch erschwerend dazu. Der hat in jedem Spiel einen horrenden Fehler drin gehabt. Es gab nicht ein Gespräch, das ich geführt habe über Lester, wo nicht der entsprechende Gesprächspartner, sei es Journalist, Fan, Verantwortliche gesagt hat, wir brauchen ihn nicht mehr. Und das als allererstes.
Ja, ja, ja. Okay, alles klar.
Ich hatte auch kurz noch einen Einwurf aus der Revisi. These war ja auch lange beeindruckt. Und der war ja auch irgendwie, glaube ich, einmal Innenverteidiger aus der Not und es war grausam. Also ich finde, er ist ein sehr guter Außenverteidiger. Aber ich habe mich auch gestern gewundert beim Blick auf die Aufstellung, dass der auf einmal EM spielt. Und da habe ich mir etwas verpasst. Aber anscheinend war das erst notgedrungen.
Ja, ist halt Personalnot. Also Eric Dyer ist ja noch da, der ist verletzt. Sali Su ist verletzt, Marisa ist verletzt. Dazu kommt auch, dass Lukas Radetzky auch schon wieder verletzt ist, der ja im Tor so ein bisschen Stabilität verleihen sollte. Dann war Zakaria auch lange verletzt, ist jetzt wieder fit. Seitdem läuft es auch zumindest so ein bisschen besser, aber man vermisst halt schon die Konstanz. Man hat auch immer wieder so unerklärliche Aussetzer drin, also Gullowin zum Beispiel, der offensive Mittelfeldspieler ist zweimal in Folge vom Platz geflogen, hat ja gegen PSG direkt nach der Pause sich natürlich, ist es ein bisschen unglücklich, weil er, glaube ich, auch wegrutscht, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem auch doof. Und besonders doof war seine letzte gelb-rote Karte in der Liga im Spiel gegen Nantes. Das war dann zwar letztendlich folgenlos, weil Monaco trotzdem 3-1 gewonnen hat, aber er hat erst eine gelbe Karte gekriegt, weil er sich im laufenden Spiel über ein angebliches Handspiel beschwert hat. Hat der Schiri das Spiel unterbrochen, hat ihm gelb gegeben, dann hat er geklatscht und dann hat er gelb-rot gekriegt. Also eine meiner absoluten Lieblingsszenen, immer wenn man für klatschen dann nochmal gelb-rot kriegt. Also und dann hat man halt auch weiterhin verletzte. Also ich glaube, das Thema Paul Pogba hatten wir ja auch schon mal kurz angerissen. Überraschenderweise hatte er noch keinen großen Impact, hat ein paar Minuten gespielt, ist jetzt aber schon wieder verletzt, steht auch nicht mehr im Champions League-Kader und ich weiß nicht, ob man davon ausgehen kann, dass er überhaupt nochmal für Monaco spielt. Also in dieser Saison wahrscheinlich nicht mehr und dass dann irgendwann nochmal was wird, weiß ich nicht. Dann fehlt mit Takumi Minamino auch noch ein wichtiger Spieler. Also es gibt halt keinerlei Fortschritt und man hat jetzt auch nicht so wirklich das Gefühl, dass die Transfers gut funktionieren würden. Man ist sich nicht so richtig klar, was will man jetzt. Hält man an Poconjoli fest, der natürlich auch so ein bisschen Opfer der Umstände sicherlich ist, aber halt auch das Problem hat, dass Hütter zum Beispiel ja auch erfolgreicher war zumindest vorher mit den ungefähr gleichen Mitteln. Und ja, es ist so ein bisschen die Frage, wo will man denn hin? Also viel mehr als die Nummer 2, Nummer 3 zu sein. In Frankreich ist ja sowieso nicht so richtig drin, aber davon ist man halt momentan auch ziemlich weit entfernt.
Also das sieht schon interessant aus. Man wird ja auch gegen PSG jetzt da noch zweimal spielen in der jüngeren Zukunft. Also einmal das Rückspiel, wo man eben das 2 zu 3 aufholen muss eventuell. Davor spielt man noch in Lens, also auch nicht so ganz super. Und Anfang März geht es dann schon wieder ins Liga-Rückspiel gegen PSG auch auswärts. Also da kommen schon ganz schöne Bretter auf Monaco zu. Ganz kurz, also muss jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen. Ich habe neulich irgendwo gelesen, PSG, jetzt wachen sie auf und jetzt werden sie quasi wieder das PSG, was wir in der Champions League in der letzten Saison gesehen haben. Ja, nein, vielleicht?
Ja, nein. Also man hatte das Gefühl jetzt schon häufiger. Es waren vor allem in der Liga allerdings jetzt zuletzt die Spiele, denn in der Champions League war man ja eher gut gestartet und hat dann zum Ende hin völlig den Faden verloren und dann ja auch noch die Top 8 verspielt, weswegen man sich ja jetzt überhaupt auch in den Playoffs nur wiederfindet. In der Liga hatte man jetzt eigentlich sieben Mal in Folge gewonnen seit Anfang Dezember, dann jetzt aber auch am Wochenende eins zu drei bei Startrennen verloren, die mit Interimstrainer angetreten sind. Nachdem man ja zuvor zum Beispiel auch 5-0 gegen Marseille gewonnen hatte im wichtigen Klassik und man so dachte, ok, jetzt ist alles wieder gut, denn Belé schießt plötzlich wieder Traumtore und irgendwie beginnt hier alles zu klicken langsam, aber sicher sind die meisten Spieler wieder fit. Aber es folgt dann in dieser Saison zumindest immer ein Rückschlag und es bleibt halt immer diese Frage, sind die Spieler jetzt alle so richtig fit, denn Belé musste jetzt gegen Monaco auch schon wieder nach 26 Minuten zwar wahrscheinlich nur leicht angeschlagen raus, aber es sind halt dann auch bei ihm jetzt ständig wieder Muskelverletzungen und diese Club-WM und dann nur diese eine Woche Pause, die sie hatten, schwebt da schon immer sehr über der ganzen Saison von PSG. Und ansonsten ist aber tatsächlich alles immer noch relativ entspannt, denn man hat ja den Titel in der Liga noch in der eigenen Hand, man spielt ja auch noch gegen Lens, man hat in der Champions League ja auch noch alles in der eigenen Hand, hat ja dann auch jetzt am Dienstag super geschafft, das 2-0 noch umzubiegen und sich in eine komfortable Position gespielt fürs Rückspiel, was dann ja auch zu Hause stattfindet, zu Hause auch schon immer eine beeindruckende Kulisse bei Paris. Und ja, es gibt auch relativ wenig Unruhe. Das einzige, was jetzt ein ganz bisschen für Fragezeichen gesorgt hat, war, dass Dembele nach der Niederlage bei Startrennen vor den Mikros gesagt hat, dass er sich wünschen würde, dass einige Spieler mehr fürs Team spielen und weniger für sich selbst. Er hat da keine Namen genannt. Es ging aber eher darum, dass es sich wahrscheinlich auf Desiree Douais bezogen hat, bei dem jetzt auffällig ist, dass er längst nicht in der Form der letzten Saison ist und vor allem vieles selbst machen will. Also dann, anstatt nochmal querzulegen, gerne den eigenen Abschluss sucht. Der hat dann jetzt gegen Monaco aber auch eine gute Antwort gegeben, ist ja eingewechselt worden, hat dann einen Doppelpack erzielt und sich auch bei beiden Toren die Ohren zugehalten. Also da so ein bisschen vielleicht auch signalisieren wollen, dass er sich ja unbeeindruckt zeigt von der Kritik. Aber je länger diese Saison dauert, desto schwerer wird es halt zu glauben, dass man jetzt nochmal so richtig das Paris der Vor-Saison sieht, da sie auch mehr Probleme haben in der Abwehr, im Tor. Alles nicht so richtig stabil wie in der letzten Saison. Und man hat halt nicht den Luxus, dass keiner verletzt ist. Das war ja in der letzten Saison auch sehr außergewöhnlich, dass man da eigentlich komplett durchgekommen ist.
So viel dazu, ohne zu sehr ins Detail zu gehen. Sehr gut, dann ist er bei Peche. Fantastisch. Genau, Bescheid. Und während wir bei Monaco schon den ersten Trainerwechsel gesehen haben, haben wir bei Tottenham den auch miterlebt. Und das bringt uns eben nach England. Und was soll ich sagen, Uli? Igor Tudor ist zurück. Warum?
Mich wundert, dass Christian noch keine Mine verzieht, weil eigentlich müsste der jetzt schon sagen, dass er es will. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was er gleich auch dazu zu sagen hat. Das ist auch ein Champions-League-Thema übrigens. Auch das ist total seltsam, aber es ist so.
Stimmt, hast recht. Erklär uns mal kurz, wie ist die Lage bei den Spurs und wie kam er denn jetzt auf Tudor? All jokes aside, was hat für ihn gesprochen?
Das ist eine wahnsinnig gute Frage, die ich dir nicht beantworten kann. Und in England suchen auch alle nach den Gründen dafür, warum es jetzt Igor Tudor ist. Also meine Idee ist, dass sie jemanden haben wollten, bis Saisonende um Zeit zu gewinnen. Das hat er oder funktioniert er gerade bei Manchester United schon mal ganz gut. Und dazu brauchst du natürlich jemanden, der glücklich ist über diese Chance und nicht unbedingt direkt schon den Blick Richtung nächste Saison gerichtet hat. Jetzt mal ohne Witz, man kann natürlich sagen, dass Tudor diese Interims-Rolle jetzt schon ordentlich übernommen hat bei einem Club, der sicherlich sogar noch mehr Wucht hat als Tottenham, das ist vermutlich die Erklärung. Allerdings, ich komme auch noch nicht so richtig ran ans sportliche Departement, was dann genau die Überlegungen dahinter sind. Also was jetzt profiltechnisch exakt für ihn gesprochen hat, ist ja dann oftmals auch einfach nur der Kontrast zu dem, der davor da war, in Thomas Frank. Das bleibt erstmal jetzt offen, das wird sich aber sicherlich jetzt auch ändern. Also in England ist ja gerade so eine ganz untypische Delle drin im Spielplan. Das heißt, die Teams, die nicht mehr im Pokal mit dabei waren, die hatten jetzt erstmal lange spielfrei Arsenal vorgezogen. Ja, aber United hat ja sogar fast 14 Tage Zeit jetzt Tottenham. Waren es glaube ich neun oder sind es jetzt neun, was natürlich auch nochmal einfach extrem verführerisch ist, um überhaupt reagiert zu haben. Und danach werden wir sicherlich auch viel, viel klüger. Die Spieler haben jetzt erstmal komplett fünf Tage frei bekommen. Auch das ist natürlich ein Zeichen dafür, dass man da jetzt was neu aufstellt. Und wenn dann alle wieder zurück sind, auch im Trainingszentrum in Anfield da, dann gehe ich davon aus, dass wir dann auch mehr Stimmen bekommen und dann auch wieder mehr Hintergründe bekommen. Aber im Moment stehe ich da relativ allein. Es gibt ein paar Gerüchte, aber das war es dann auch schon.
Ja, ich wollte nur kurz, weil es Uli ja schon angerissen hat. Ich habe mitbekommen aus England, dass da viele Kommentare sind so ungefähr, da hat sich jetzt die Hölle aufgetan mit Igor Tudor oder so ungefähr. Also, dass es ganz, ganz schlimm wäre. Ich wollte nur anbringen aus italienischer Sicht. Uli hat es ja schon angerissen. Zum einen hat er letztes Jahr die Mission mit Juve erfüllt, nämlich eben in die Saison reinkommen, sie in die Champions League zu bringen. Das war ganz klar das Ziel, das hat er geschafft. Und es war nicht das erste Mal, sondern das selbe hat er bei Lazio auch schon geschafft. Da ist er auch unter der Saison gekommen, hat Lazio noch in die Europa League geführt. Also, er hat sich jetzt anscheinend so ein bisschen, ich nenne es jetzt mal ein bisschen hochqualifizierteren Feuerwehrmann, sozusagen Etikette, die hat er sich erspielt. Und in Italien sagen auch alle, so wie es Uli gesagt hat, in Italien ist es eigentlich, da wird nicht mal hinter dem Hof gehalten, sondern es ist ganz klar, ja logisch, das ist eine Lösung bis zum Sommer. Tottenham schaut sich jetzt halt in Ruhe um. Und die hoffen halt darauf, dass Tudor das, was er bei Juve geschafft hat, was er bei Lazio geschafft hat, in relativ kurzer Zeit da wieder ein bisschen Energie reinzubringen. Und für ihn logisch, wie es Uli sagt, ist logisch cooler Move, da bei Tottenham jetzt auch ein paar Monate zu sein. Auf der anderen Seite, ja, wenn du dann eigentlich schon weißt, dass du im Sommer auch schon wieder weg bist, ja, weiß jetzt auch nicht, was seine persönliche Perspektive dann danach ist. Aber ja, ganz klar aus Italien hat man auch deutlich so vernommen. Es geht darum, die jetzt relativ schnell auf Kurs zu bringen.
Wäre aber auch nicht das erste Mal, dass ein Trainer, wenn er bei den Big Six einen halbwegs brauchbaren Job macht, einfach sich dann sozusagen ins Schaufenster stellt für kleinere Aufgaben. Und es heißt jetzt nur ein ambitioniertes Championship Team. Also, es wird ja, werden wir auch noch darüber sprechen, es wird dieses Jahr einen großen Namen erwischen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch nicht so schlecht, dann mit falschen Umzahlungen in die zweite Liga zu gehen, da wirklich ernsthaft eine Philosophie einzuziehen. Da gehe ich mal davon aus, dass das auch eine Idee ist von Camp Tudor, dass man einfach dann mal in England aufgeschlagen ist und eben nicht weiterhin nur. Also, dabei auch in Frankreich, glaube ich, mal kurz. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es ja eine italienische Biografie bis dato.
Und um aber noch mal kurz auf die Entlassung von Thomas Frank zurückzukommen, also wenn man sich den Tabellenplatzverlauf des Burrs anguckt, dann ist es wie die Stelvio. So geht es ziemlich steil zwischendurch mal runter. Musste es so kommen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also, das ist nicht, wie so oft im Fußball, es ist nicht ganz frei von Politik diese Entscheidung. Also sowohl, dass er lange das Vertrauen bekommen hat, als auch, dass er dann jetzt zum Schluss aber entlassen worden ist. Es gab eine Zeit lang eine sportliche Doppelspitze. Wir haben das, glaube ich, auch mal thematisiert hier mit Fabio Paratici, der eine Zeit lang da war, dann ja gesperrt war, dann wieder kam und der zählt noch recht deutlich zum alten Regime unter Daniel Livi, also dem langjährigen Chairman, der auch das Stadionprojekt verwirklicht hat und so. Und logischerweise, wenn jemand so lang, so stark mit einem Verein war, dann hat der seine Gefolge weiterhin. Und dazu zählte wohl auch Paratici, der sehr deutlich gemacht hat, schon sehr früh, dass Thomas Frank nicht der richtige Mann sei. Das ist ja der letzte, das kann man jetzt ganz offiziell sagen, der letzte Trainer der Daniel Livi-Ära. Und auf der anderen Seite ist Jürgen Lange, der gerade dabei ist, sich sowas wie Macht zu verschaffen innerhalb des Vereins, der ein sehr ruhiger, sehr hintergründiger Vertreter ist und ein sehr, sehr sachlicher. Also ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass dieser Prozess der Entlassung auch wirklich gnadenlos datenbasiert war am Ende. Und der wollte Thomas Frank so lang wie es geht irgendwie halten. Jetzt gibt es aber die Familie Lewis, der Tottenham mehrheitlich gehört, die Tochter des Haupteigners, also sozusagen der Schwiegersohn von Mr. Lewis, der kommt wohl sehr stark gerade um die Ecke und zeigt sich und möchte jetzt mehr hands-on sein. Und da kommt wohl auch, also das muss man super vorsichtig sein, aber da kommt wohl auch diese Idee der Entlassung dann jetzt her. Und jetzt kommt, das muss man ja schon sagen, es kommen nach und nach jetzt Sachen auf über Thomas Frank, der, das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, aber der Tottenham mehrfach versucht hat zu motivieren mit Arsenal-Vergleichen, was natürlich ein bisschen schwierig ist, den Lokalrevalen zu nennen. Auch wenn ich verstehe, worauf er hinaus möchte. Und grundsätzlich wohl ein bisschen zu kumpelhaft war im Umgang. Was mich total gewundert hatte, ist– also, wir müssen dann sportlich auch gleich noch zwei, drei Sätze drüber verlieren, weil da kann man einerseits, andererseits sagen. Aber was mich total gewundert hatte, und wo ich eigentlich Thomas Franks große Stärke begriffen habe, ist, dass es ihm kommunikativ, auch öffentlich, brutal aus den Händen geraten ist. Das hätte ich niemals für möglich gehalten, weil ich den für den talentiertesten Rhetoriker überhaupt im europäischen Fußball gehalten habe. Deswegen habe ich ja immer gesagt, wenn ich Borussia Dortmund wäre, würde ich übrigens immer noch tun, trotzdem, würde ich mir immer mal überlegen, so jemanden zu holen, der einfach so ein Umfeld wahnsinnig gut befeuern und aber auch bedienen kann und dich dachte, auch befrieden könnte. Das hat er nicht geschafft, das muss man so ehrlich sagen. Das habe ich auch aus intern schon gehört, dass das durchaus auch für Verwunderung gesorgt hat, weil sie ebenfalls bei der Recherche eine Vorverpflichtung beim Stand waren, dass der das problemlos machen könnte. Hat er nicht getan. Ist halt dann einfach doch noch mal ein ganz anderes Kaliber als Brentford. Das muss man dann wohl so feststellen.
Und was sind deine sportlichen Takes?
Also nochmal ganz– ich versuche es nur, in aller Kürze zu sagen– was bei Thomas Frank die Idee war, war von vornherein laden, zusperren, also Zentrum dicht und Standard-Situationen erarbeiten, weil sie gedacht haben, sie sind eines der stärksten Standard-Teams der Premier League. Das hat auch so weit funktioniert.
Ah, sie wollten wie Asen sein. Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Genau, sie wollten wie Asen sein. Ganz genau. Den Vergleich soll es echt mehrfach gegeben haben. Das hat auch zum Teil funktioniert. Aber keine Kreativität aus der Mitte, nichts Progressives. Also es war viel zur Seite, kaum was nach vorne. Also sozusagen das Umschalten hat komplett gefehlt. Output von den Flügelstürmern war 0,0 da. Aber, und das ist der Punkt und das kauf ich so, Kulusevski, ganz komische Personalie mit Abstand. Der beste Spieler der vergangenen Saison, der Produktivste, der Kreativste, kannst alle Attribute für Offensivspieler jetzt dahin stecken. Der spielt nicht und sie wissen nicht genau, warum. Der reagiert ständig, also sein Knie reagiert ständig auf irgendwelche Dinge. Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir ihn nicht mehr sehen werden in der Saison, aber inzwischen, ehrlich gesagt. Madison, der zweite richtig gute Mann in der Offensive, was Kreativität betrifft, auch nicht da. Kreuzbandriss, ganze Saison raus. Odobert hat sich jetzt neuerlich verletzt. Das war der Einzige, der so etwas wie eins gegen eins möglich gemacht hat. Das ist ein Problem und das ist im Übrigen ein Problem, das Tottenham jetzt schon im zweiten Jahr in Folge hat. Und jetzt könnte man sagen, okay, jetzt haben sie wieder nicht, also auch den zweiten Winter in Folge, Riesenverletzungsproblematik und sie verpflichten einfach nichts. Und das ist seltsam, wenngleich– also nichts stimmt nicht, sie haben Conor Gallagher geholt, aber das war nicht das Problem, einen zentralen Mittelfeldmotor zu haben. Das war jetzt nicht das große Problem. Auch eins, aber nicht das ganz große. Einzelne Spieler sind wahnsinnig liturgisch mitunter, also talentiert, aber liturgisch. Also gar nicht immer nur aus bösem Willen heraus, sondern scheinen viele sehr, sehr sensible Spieler drin zu sein. Schavi zum Beispiel, der jetzt im letzten Spiel von Thomas Frank, das kann man gar nicht was zu sagen, ohne dass seine Tottenham-Fans aufs Dach steigen. Aber am Ball hat er mir noch echt gut gefallen, weil er mal was probiert hat, was auch selten, also es war ganz oft so, dass man das Gefühl hatte, der ist total eingeschüchtert. Aber gegen den Ball, und wir alle wissen aus Leipziger-Zeiten vielleicht noch, das hat er schon drin, der kann das schon, ein guter Gegenpresser sein. Und gegen den Ball hat er sich halt gar nichts gegönnt. Petro Poro läuft rum wie falsch Geld. Dann hast du, das ist ja auch so ein Thema, Kapitän in Cristian Romero, der in 150 Spielen 6 Mal vom Platz geflogen ist. Unter anderem dann ja auch gegen Manchester United wieder vom Platz geflogen ist wegen der Undiszipliner. Ich lasse mir auch nichts anderes einreden. Also auch wenn mir viele Leute dann geschrieben haben, ja das war doch alles gar nicht absichtlich, das ist sowas von absichtlich. Ich habe es glaube ich 3 oder 4 Schiedsrichterinnen gezeigt, die alle straight away geschrieben haben. Runter mit dem, der weiß genau, was er tut. Und der hat sich jetzt mehrfach öffentlich schon geäußert, dass er in Tottenham werde nicht genügend investiert. Er hat dann nochmal den alten Trainer nachhinein gelobt, das natürlich auch super ist für den neuen. Und dann im Spiel darauf kommt dann so eine Aktion, er fliegt vom Platz und dann sieht Van der Wehen wieder schlecht aus, der es eigentlich ganz gut macht. Ja, und so ist am Ende dann. Und mein größter Punkt bei Thomas Frank, und da bin ich ja schon am Ende, also schon ist gut, aber mein größter Punkt bei Thomas Frank ist, in all dieser Phase habe ich nie verstanden, dass er nicht bei einem System bleibt. Ich glaube nämlich, das hätte der Mannschaft wahnsinnig gut getan, dass sie zumindest wissen, was zu tun ist. Er hat ständig was versucht, das habe ich jeweils für jedes Spiel auch so verstanden, was er wollte. Aber das trägt halt nicht dazu bei, dass sensible, unsichere, zum Teil auch müde Spieler dann richtig gut laufen. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine komplizierte Sache, der da jetzt zusammenführt. Aber das sind, glaube ich, die zentralen Punkte.
Sehr gut. Vielen Dank dir. Und damit sind wir mit den Champions League-Teams durch, beziehungsweise vielleicht doch noch nicht so ganz, Daniel. Denn wir sprechen jetzt über ein Team, das in der Eredivisie auf Rang 3 liegt und damit nur 3 Punkte hinter einem Champions League-Platz. Schaffen sie es denn noch?
Genau so sieht es aus. Ich wollte auch ähnlich anmoderieren. Und auf Platz 3 wäre ja sogar immerhin die Quali für die CL. Also selbst das 3 könnte reichen, je nach Verlauf. Und ja, ob sie es schaffen, ist eine gute Frage. Also der Status quo ist, dass sie aktuell punktgleich sind. Nijmegen mit Ajax, die sich zuletzt, also Ajax ein bisschen stabilisiert haben. Das heißt da Tottenhamer Gefahren, dass mit Australien noch mal sie von Ajax abgelöst wird. Aber grundsätzlich halte ich es auf jeden Fall für möglich. Und diese Geschichte über Nijmegen, da muss man ein bisschen weiter zurückgehen. Das ist nämlich recht interessant. Also Nijmegen, so ungefähr vor 9 oder 10 Jahren, also ihr merkt, ich gehe wirklich ein bisschen weit zurück, sind sie abgestiegen, also da war wirklich, es war so ein Herr, guter alter HSV Chaos Club war Nijmegen. Da war also nicht nur auf dem Platz, sondern auch Unternehmen im Vorstand und viele Baustellen. Und die haben sie mit dem Abstieg dann aber radikal geschlossen und sind dann 21 wieder aufgestiegen unter Maja-Ex, dem Ex-Trainer und haben dann erst mal, die letzten Jahre, eigentlich immer sehr nicht vorsichtig agiert, aber sportlich, fußballerisch eher defensiv, stabilität geachtet und sind damit auch ganz gut gefahren. Also die waren eigentlich dann nie wirklich ein Abstiegsgefahr der letzten Jahre, konnten sich immer gut in der Liga halten. Und man hat dann aber in der vergangenen Song, als es eine kleine Dürrephase gab, und dann Maja gesagt, okay, wir wollen den Vertrag jetzt nicht mehr verlängern. Man hat dann gesagt, beiseitig sich entschieden, das dann zu beenden. Ist aber am guten auseinander. Es gab auch wirklich Tränen und Rührungen im letzten Spieltag, vergangenen Song mit Maja. Man ist wirklich gut auseinander, wollte aber was Neues probieren. Und vor allem wollte man wirklich einen Kurswechsel haben, weg von dieser eher defensiven Spielweise hin zu einer neuen, offensiven Spielweise. Und dafür hat man dann Dick Schreuder geholt. Den kann man noch kennen, der war unter seinem Bruder Alfred, Co-Trainer an Hoffenheim. Ist ein bisschen her. Aber da ist er, den könnte man nicht von kennen. Und Dick Schreuder ist in den Niederlanden eigentlich bekannt für wirklich wilden Offensiv-Fußball. Und er selbst nennt es kontrolliertes Chaos. Es geht ja eigentlich so ein bisschen in diese typische 4-3-3-oranje-Fußballschule, Al-Ax-Fußballschule. Und er hat das auch mal ein bisschen angepasst nach seinem Gusto. Und in der Presse ist dann oft von Dickie-Taka die Rede. Dick Schreuder, also tolles Wortspiel. Und das hat er jetzt quasi über NEC Nijmegen gestülpt. Und es ist sehr interessant, also er lässt mit einem mit einer Dreierkette aufbauen, hat dann auf den Außenbahn ein sehr offensives Verständnis von den Wingbacks. Er selbst sagt, Wingback möchte er sie nicht nennen aufgrund dieser offensiven Ausrichtung. Und er hat auch ganz interessant in der Vorbereitung mal ein Interview gegeben, wo er gesagt hat, ja also idealerweise erkennt man sein System eigentlich nicht. Und das ist so sein Traum, wenn man sieht, okay Dreierkette im Aufbau, aber der Rest vorne ist immer in Bewegung, ist immer Vogel wild. Das findet er gut. Und er war wohl mit Nijmegen bei der Vorbereitung bei irgendeinem großen Datenkonzern. Und da gab es so ein Tool, wo man Trainer suchen konnte. Und der hat sich dann quasi selbst gesucht und eingegeben. Und war dann sehr froh, dass dann bei seinem Namentradstand keine Formation gefunden. Also das fand er, das fand er super. Und ja, das beschreibt glaube ich ihn und die Spielweise von Nijmegen auch gut. Ganz gut und das hat vor allem zu Beginn auch schon direkt funktioniert. Was ja eigentlich nicht selbstverständlich ist, wenn du quasi ein komplett neues System auf einen, ja, sag ich mal gehobener Mitgliedslaßung-Club sportlich, was die damals waren, draufsetzt. Und es ist, also er gibt viel Risiko, also so die Merkmale kann man glaube ich auch schon erahnen. Also so schnell das Mittelfeld überbrücken, hoher Druck ausüben, viele Leute, im Gegenteil schon Sechzehner. Und ist so ein bisschen, was Feyenoord diese Saison auch so ein bisschen macht. Und ist auch sehr interessant seine drei Info-Leiniger, die starten teilweise auch beim Aufbau von Tiefenläufe und scheißen sich mit dem Angriff ein. Und ja, das hat gut funktioniert. Und was auch ein wichtiger Baustand ist für diesen Erfolg, sind auch die passenden Spiele für das System. Also da rauszuheben ist zum Beispiel ein Kodaisano, das ist 22, genau 22 glaube ich, und hat echt eine totale passschärfe Passgenauigkeit. Also die ersten Spiele waren immer an so 90-91% Passgenauigkeit dran. Über die Distanz jetzt von 23 Spielen ist die Wette ein bisschen gesunken, aber ist immer noch ein herausragender Passgeber und Ballverteiler. Und das brauchst du dann eben auch in so einem System, um zu funktionieren. Und zur Wahrheit gehört, dass es dann auch in den letzten beiden Spielen nicht mehr so rund lief, da gab es auch eine Nijanlage unentschieden gegen Sparta Rotterdam, also ein eher kleineren Verein. Was daran liegen kann natürlich, dass einerseits die Teams ein bisschen auf eingestellt haben und aber auch, dass das halt dieses Risiko relativ groß ist. Wenn dann mal so ein Impfteiliger den Ball verliert, dann hast du als hinten kaum noch eine gute Absicherung. Das ist dann auch schon jetzt einiges mal passiert, aber im Großen und Ganzen geht es noch auf. Und wir können gespannt sein, wohin der Weg noch führt.
Aber wirklich, und es geht jetzt ja direkt zu Ajax am nächsten Spieltag. Man wird im Halbfinale des Pokals noch gegen PSV zu Hause spielen. Also, Dick Schreuder, wer hätte gedacht, dass wir noch über einen Schreuder hier sprechen?
Ja.
Und klingt wirklich hochinteressant. Und es ist immer was los. Also zweitbeste Defensive der Liga, aber weil du es angesprochen hast, die Offensive, Entschuldigung. Und die Defensive ist aber tatsächlich die drittschlechteste. Also sprich, wenn ihr Tore sehen wollt, wenn was passieren soll, ja dann, dann guckt ein Nijmegen. Das lohnt sich.
Genau. Und was man auch sagen muss, es sind auch, in Nijmegen stecken echt auch viele Geschichten in Geschichten. Also wir haben zum Beispiel Theron Czeri, der Kamp von Antwerpen, ist 37 für einen Feldspieler und hat nochmal den x-ten Frühling, Herbst, wie man sagt, erlebt er, also auch schon jetzt, glaube ich, 6 Tore, 5 Assists in der Saison und ist wirklich, sehr viel Freiheiten, bewegt sich nicht so viel, aber findet die Orte, wo er sich bewegen muss. Und das funktioniert dann sehr gut. Und das ist auch, der war in China, in der Türkei, in Israel, der ist sehr viel von der Welt gesehen und ist jetzt wirklich eine zentrale Figur auch bei Nijmegen. Was so ein bisschen vielleicht noch das Ganze abrunden würde, wäre vielleicht noch so ein Spielertyp à la Bourg, Oliver Bourg, quasi der Schauspieler mit dem Bart, wie er anzi nennt wurde. So dass man vielleicht von Spielern hat, der Tempo und diese Körperlichkeit beides, wo du vielleicht auch mal von der Bank bringen kannst, bei Rückstand, die sie jetzt hatten in den letzten Spielen. Das fehlt noch so ein bisschen, aber ansonsten ist das ein Team, was echt spannend ist. Und man muss halt auch gucken, also Wolfsburg zum Beispiel hat sich ja gerade bedient aus Nijmegen mit Shio Guy, der gekommen ist. Das merkt man auch schon, dass Nijmegen jetzt ein bisschen fehlt in der Offensive. Und da haben sie jetzt den Isländer mit dem tollen Namen Willum Willumsohn geholt. Mal gucken, ob der da die Rollerheit bei Maxima.
Das ist wirklich ein fantastischer Name. Ja, sehr schön. Und sag mir noch ganz kurz, ist es NEC Nijmegen oder ist es NEC Nijmegen?
NEC Nijmegen.
Deswegen habe ich mich nämlich nicht getraut, den Verein anzumoderieren. Aber wenn du gesagt hast, sie liegen auf Platz 3, dachte ich mir so, jetzt höre ich mal ganz genau hin, da hast du es nicht gesagt. Deswegen musste ich jetzt fragen, wieso ein Depp. Okay, NEC Nijmegen. Merken wir uns auf jeden Fall und kann man wirklich sehr gespannt sein auf das Spiel bei Ajax. Dann blicken wir jetzt nochmal nach Italien und Christian, da du gleich los musst, sag uns mal noch, was du uns noch mitgebracht hast, deine zwei kürzeren Themen.
Ja, sehr gerne. Ich würde am Anfang mal ein bisschen auf den Abstiegskampf schauen. Da hat nämlich Lecce die letzten zwei Spiele gewonnen, sechs Punkte geholt und damit das Ganze nochmal richtig angezündet. Also kurzer Blick auf die Tabelle, Pisa und Verona sind abgeschlagen auf letzten und vorletzten Platz. Die haben mittlerweile schon neun Punkte Rückstand auf dem ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz. Also ich glaube, die sind so gut wie weg. Aber dann wird es richtig eng. Die Fiorentina ist immer noch auf dem Abstiegsprang mit 21 Punkten und dann ist jetzt eben Lecce, Cremonaise und Genoa mit 24 Punkten. Also wir haben sozusagen vier Mannschaften innerhalb von nur drei Punkten. Da wird einer runtergehen. Und Lecce hat sich dann, wie gesagt, bis vor ein paar Wochen war immer so ein bisschen der Tenor, ja gut, Lecce wird es erwischen. Aber die haben jetzt eben zuletzt Caliari und Udinese geschlagen und haben dadurch auch wieder eben Genoa und Cremonaise voll mit reingezogen. Und deswegen lohnt vielleicht ein kleiner Blick auf Lecce, nämlich da habe ich euch einen, wie ich finde, relativ spannenden, interessanten Mann mitgebracht, der mir davor auch nicht groß was gesagt hat. Lecce hat im Winter ein bisschen nachgelegt. Und zwar haben sie einen Omri Gandelmann geholt aus Belgien. Das ist ein israelischer Offensiv- und Mittelfeldspieler, vom KAA Gent geholt. Der hat in der Hinterrunde, in Belgien, 7 Tore gemacht. Also der weiß, wo das Tor steht. Und ja, der hat jetzt bei diesen zwei Siegen jeweils auch getroffen. Und Eusebio Di Francesco, der Trainer von Lecce, meint eben genau, dass er genau der Typ ist, der uns gefehlt hat, offensiver Mittelfeldspieler, der Torgefahr mitbringt, der wirklich auch teilweise aus dem Spiel heraus dann als zweiter Stürmer agiert, sozusagen. Und das sieht man halt wieder. Wir haben ja oft darüber gesprochen, ja, im Winter. Wen findest du? Wintertransfers, oft große Fragezeichen. Aber Lecce scheint da wieder mal ein guter Griff gelungen zu sein. Zur Erinnerung vielleicht ganz kurz, Pantaleo Corvino, der Sportdirektor, das ist ja so ein Sportdirektor, ein Guru in Italien seit Jahrzehnten, einer der besten, der hat Jovovic, Stjertle, Vlaović, ganz viele damals bei der Fiorentina auch geholt. Also wirklich große Namen in der Vergangenheit. Ja, und da haben sie ja anscheinend wieder ein Juwel gefunden. Da war, Gandelmann war Kapitän der israelischen Olympia-Auswahl, 24, jetzt auch israelischer Nationalspieler. Und ja, vielleicht ist er jetzt das Puzzlestück sozusagen, das Lettche auf jeden Fall wieder mal ins Rennen eingebracht hat. Ja, und vielleicht auch einer, der dafür sorgen kann, dass sozusagen da, ja, das Lettche am Ende womöglich auch drin bleibt. Und noch ein Satz dazu, Wintertransfer ja auch auf so eine Sache kennen wir ja auch Richtung Deadline Day. Ganz viel passiert halt spät. Corvino hat es geschafft, Gandelmann schon Anfang Januar zu verpflichten. Das heißt, er hat jetzt schon sieben Ligaspiele bestritten. Also in Italien gab es ja keine Winterpause, die haben durchgespielt. Sprich, der hat schon, ich glaube, um 10. Januar sein erstes Pflichtspiel für Lettche gemacht, kam gut rein in Rhythmus und jetzt eben scheint er ein richtig großer Faktor zu sein. Also das ist vielleicht auch so ein kleines Nebenthema. Es lohnt sich manchmal halt auch in den Transferperioden früh zuzuschlagen, weil du dann halt deinem Team oder deinem Trainer halt bessere Möglichkeiten ergibst, die neuen dann halt auch früher oder besser einzubauen.
3. Ganz kurz, wenn die Hörerinnen und Hörer sich denken, Lecce, wann habe ich Lecce in der Transferperiode gehört? Vielleicht als Yami Siebert dorthin gewechselt ist von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Und ansonsten noch bei Lecce Sadeg-Wofana, der ja aus Aachen kommt und Christian Früchtl, der mir vor vielen, vielen Jahren von Bayern-Fans als Nächster Manuel Neuer vorgestellt wurde. Jetzt sitzt er auf der Bank bei Lecce.
Ja, aber da kann man jetzt logisch vielleicht bei Lecce auf der Bank sitzen und lächeln. Das hat aber auch damit zu tun, dass mit Falcone einer der sehr, sehr guten italienischen Torhüter da bei Lecce spielt. Also ich würde mal sagen, Früchtl in der anderen Konstellation hätte auch schon Einsätze bekommen. Aber Falcone ist eigentlich für ein Team wie Lecce überqualifiziert. Also Falcone würde ich in der Serie A zu den Top 5, 6 Torhütern zählen, 7 vielleicht auf jeden Fall. Also da hat er schon durchaus auch, sag ich mal, obwohl er für einen kleinen Verein spielt oder zu einem kleinen Verein gewechselt hat, aber da hat er einfach mit Falcone einen Vorsicht, der ja wirklich eigentlich für zu höhere Berufe war. Deswegen zieht man von Früchtl eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts, weil Falcone einfach ein richtiger Klassemann ist. Genau.
Es sollte auch nicht gegen Früchtl gehen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich wollte nur bezogen und sagen, weil man könnte ja meinen… Ich weiß, dass manche dieser Fans nämlich den Podcast hören, die mir damals gesagt haben, schau dir den Früchtl an, das wird der neue nach vorne. Aber gut.
Und wo man letztes Jahr vielleicht auch die letzten Jahre mitbekommen haben, sie immer gut verkauft, Dorgo letzte Saison ja zu Manchester United, der spielt ja jetzt auch nicht die ganz die schlechteste Figur. Gibt die ab, Hjulmand bei Benfica oder okay, Uli schüttelt den Kopf. Aber ich glaube, eine Zeit lang hat er schon viel Stamm gespielt, oder Uli? Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Er wäre nicht der Erste, der im System am Amorim so seine Schwierigkeiten hatte. Jetzt in etwas offensiverer Rolle ist es echt okay.
Ich meinte damit nur, dass ein Spieler von Lecce direkt von Lecce kommen, bei United dann relativ viel Starteinsätze hat, würde ich jetzt sagen, ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt ein Muss bei den Kadern, wie es in der Premier League da ist.
Nee, nee, also alles in Ordnung. Ich glaube, da kann eher weniger dafür als der Trainer.
Ja, genau. Und Jülmand eben, Benfica, also Lecce ist sehr bekannt dafür, immer wieder sehr gut zu verkaufen. Sind seit Jahren schon das Team mit dem kleinsten Italien der Serie A und schaffen es deswegen immer wieder mal durch cleverer Transfers, sowohl beim Verkaufen als auch beim Kauf, sich drin zu halten. Und ja, vielleicht ist dieser Omri Gandlmann jetzt das kleine Puzzlestück, das nächste, das da mithelfen kann. Jakob?
Wann sehen wir denn die ersten Einsatzminuten für Nico Kovac bei Lecce? Aus der Primavera. Der saß auf der Bank am Wochenende immerhin.
Ja, Lecce gehört auch dazu. Die haben einen sehr guten, haben die letzten Jahre auch schon Primavera-Titel in Italien gewonnen. Also eine sehr, sehr gute Nachwuchsarbeit ist auch ein eigenes Thema. Wird manchmal etwas kritisch gesehen in Italien, denn die haben zwar die Primavera-Saison gewonnen, aber fast nur mit ausländischen Spielern gespielt. Also auch da sieht man dann eben den Einfluss von Corvina, dass da sehr viele Talente früh geholt werden. Aber ja, da kommen immer wieder auch aus der Jugend spannende, spannende, spannende Namen nach.
Okay, Nico Kovac kommt übrigens von Eintracht Frankfurt. Aber jetzt noch dein zweites kurzes Thema, denn dann musst du ja wirklich mal langsam los, Christian.
Ja, nee, alles gut. Ja, ich würde sagen, schönes Thema. Eduardo Bove, ich glaube, sagt den meisten, Fußball interessiert noch was. Das war der junge italienische Spieler, der jetzt mittlerweile vor mehr als einem Jahr ja beim Spiel Fiorentina gegen Inter auf dem Platz kollabiert ist, wo es ja das Herz sozusagen nicht mehr mitgemacht hat. Logisch dramatische Szenen damals wusste man ja nicht, wie es mit ihm weitergehen wird. Und Eduardo Bove ist auf dem Fußballplatz zurückgekehrt. Und zwar hat er bei Watford unterschrieben und hat jetzt eben sein Debüt gefeiert bei Watford, vergangene Woche, also in der Championship, nach mehr als ein Jahr, es war Dezember 224, also jetzt ein Jahr und drei Monate. Hintergrund der Geschichte, vielleicht erinnerst du dich auch noch ein paar, er hat dann im Zuge eines medizinischen Eingriffs einen ICD sozusagen eingesetzt bekommen, also einen Defibrillator, einen implantierbaren Defibrillator. Und in Italien ist es so, dass das eben nicht erlaubt ist, mit solchen herzunterstützenden Mitteln zu spielen. Im Prinzip ist es die gleiche Geschichte wie bei Christian Eriksen. Erinnerst du dich vielleicht auch noch ein paar, der ja damals, als ihm das schlimme Schicksal bei der EM passiert ist, ja bei Inter unter Vertrag stand, da auch eine wichtige sportliche Rolle innehatte, aber eben aufgrund der Regularien in Italien nicht mehr weiterspielen durfte. Und ja, auch wie bei Eriksen, führt jetzt der Weg von Borwe eben nach England, weil in England ist das erlaubt. Und ja, wie gesagt, schöne Geschichte, war Riesen, Riesenfreude auch in Italien, dass er zurückkommt. Er war ja ursprünglich noch bei der Roma unter Vertrag, war ja damals an die Fiorentina ausgeliehen, aber die Roma hat dann logisch in beidseiten Einvernehmen haben sie den Vertrag aufgelöst, weil klar war, eben mit diesem ICD wird er in Italien nicht mehr spielen können. Und umso schöner, dass er jetzt wieder auf dem Platz zurück ist. Ganz schöne emotionale Szenen, seine ganze Familie war da. Ja, schöner Moment. Und ich bin gespannt, weil Borwe, erinnern Sie sich vielleicht auch noch ein paar, der hatte damals bei der Fiorentina wirklich auch eine richtig, richtig gute sportliche Rolle. Also wenn der wirklich vielleicht wieder, ja, in den Modus reinkommen sollte, wäre ihm ja zu wünschen. Das war damals ein Spieler, der war nicht weit weg von der Nationalmannschaft. Also deswegen ist das Allerwichtigste, das würde ich sagen, dass es ihm gut geht, dass er wieder Profisport betreiben kann. Aber wer weiß, vielleicht, wenn er sich da wirklich wieder rein beißt, dann sehen wir den in den nächsten Jahren auch noch mal nicht nur, unter Anführungszeichen, in der Championship, sondern vielleicht auch höher. Das Potenzial ist definitiv da. Und letzter Satz, das Vertrauen von Wattford ist auch sehr groß, denn er hat einen 5,5-Jahres-Vertrag.
Toll.
Also, der hat jetzt im Winter unterschrieben und das war jetzt nicht einfach nur so, ja, komm, hier, kurzer Vertrag, sondern 5,5. Also, da scheint wirklich auch großes Vertrauen einfach in ihn da zu sein. Ja, schöne Geschichte.
Weißt du, dass zufällig, wenn er sich jetzt wieder in die Nationalmannschaft reinspielen würde, dürfte er dann auf italienischem Boden auflaufen?
Gute Frage, Max. Habe ich jetzt nicht parat, aber könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das womöglich bei Heimspielen nicht gehen würde. Weil, wie gesagt, da redet ja die italienische, sozusagen, da geht es ja auch um italienische medizinische Standards. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die auch für Nationalmannschaftsspiele gelten. Also, ja, das ist ein spannendes Thema. Also, wenn es wirklich so kommen sollte, ob er dann, unter Anführungszeichen, ein auswärts Nationalspieler werden würde.
Die andere Form des Legionärs.
Ja, genau. Also, ich würde es nicht ausschließen, dass es wirklich auf italienischen Boden einfach nicht geht, sozusagen.
Aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, viel zu... Genau.
Es geht hier nicht mehr weiter. Genau, absolut. Es ist schön. Er hat sich zurückgebissen, hat auch ja immer direkt danach schon gesprochen, nach dem Vorfall, er möchte alles dafür tun, wieder auf den Platz zurückzukommen. Und ja, war jetzt ein großes Echo in Italien. Und ja, können wir ihm, glaube ich, alle die Daumen drücken.
Aber wirklich, das tun wir. Christian, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Du verabschiedest dich an dieser Stelle. Bis bald mal wieder in der Ligatur. Mach's gut.
Ja, danke. Sorry, dass ich jetzt so abrupt los muss. Ich wünsche euch noch ganz viel Spaß. Danke schön.
Ciao.
So, und Nils, wenn du magst, dann darfst du mal weitermachen. Du hast uns ein bisschen Chaos mitgebracht. Diesmal aber nicht kontrolliertes Chaos, wie wir es gerade bei den Nijmegen hatten.
Ja, so ungefähr. Nö, es ist immer wieder typisch La Liga, was da so los ist. Es geht jetzt gar nicht unbedingt um die sportliche Situation. Bei RAIO war Elcano. Die sind als Tabellen 17 natürlich in akuter Abstiegsgefahr. Aber bei RAIO ist jetzt die letzten Heimspiele. Was passiert oder nicht passiert, wo man drüber reden muss, was sinnbildlich für einen Club ist, der natürlich irgendwo als Kultig gilt. Und ja, ich bin auch einmal im Jahr gerne dort und denke mir, hier riecht es wieder was schön nach Urin. Also das Stadion ist super runtergewirtschaftet und sogar so super runtergewirtschaftet, dass das auch…
Dieses Kultig, okay.
Das ist das Kultig. Oh, wow, hier ist alles voller Dreck und Tauben, Kot und Ratten, na, das ist irgendwie… Manche sagen halt, das ist kultig und historisch. Jetzt war es eben so weit, dass sie, sie hätten am 7. Februar ein Heimspiel gegen Real Oviedo haben müssen. Das wäre um 14 Uhr gewesen und um 10.14 Uhr kam vom La Liga-Verband die Absage. Weil, nicht weil irgendwie, das gab es auch schon mal, es wurden mal Kabel durchgeschnitten, da ist dann ein Spiel von Riamat Ripp dort ausgefallen, also durch irgendwie Sachbeschädigung. Nö, weil der Platz nicht in guten Bedingungen war, dass dort das Gesundheitsrisiko für die Spieler zu hoch, zu gefährlich war. Wirklich absoluter Flickenteppich seit Monaten eigentlich schon. Und wie gesagt, es geht nicht nur darum, dass rund um das Stadion Flutlichtanlage aus, ich weiß nicht, den 60ern und alles irgendwie, man traut sich nicht auf die Sitzschalen hinzusetzen und die Kabinen, es war mal Lech Posen zu Conference League Spiel dort im Einsatz. Die hatten dann so eine kleine Room Tour durch die Kabine gemacht und man denkt sich, oh mein Gott, wie konnten die überhaupt die Lizenz für Conference League bekommen? Haben sich dort ja auch sportlich gut geschlagen, direkt qualifiziert für die K.o. Runde. Also sportlich ist das eine bei Radio, aber das drum herum um den Club ist ja teils katastrophal. An dem Vortag von dieser Spielabsage gegen Real Oviedo hatte sogar noch die Spanische Spieler-Gewerkschaft AFE eine Mitteilung rausgebracht von der ersten Mannschaft, also von den Spielern direkt, die da die ganzen Missstände mal darauf hingewiesen haben, dass sie teilweise gar nicht auf dem Trainingsgelände trainieren können, dass auch die Jugend- und Frauenabteilung komplett vernachlässigt werden. Es gab auch schon unter der Saison Berichte von irgendwie Schiedsrichtern, die irgendwie benutzte Handtücher dann angeboten bekommen nach so einem Spiel und wirklich katastrophale Zustände. Und da sind wir jetzt bei dem großen Namen, wo der natürlich da die primäre Verantwortung trägt. Das ist der Präsident Martin Presa oder genauer sogar der Eigentümer des Klubs, der schon seit Jahren da im Fokus der Fans ist. Da hört man schon öfter mal Presa, WD, ja, also Presa, hau ab. Der, wie gesagt, den Klub da enorm runterwirtschaftet. Und jetzt gab es diese eine Absage gegen Real Oviedo. Nachholt Spieltermin noch nicht in Sicht und das Spiel danach gegen Atletico. Da mussten sie dann ausweichen. Sie haben zwar versucht, neuen Rasen anzuflanzen, aber auch der sieht sehr flickenmäßig aus. Und das hat nicht gereicht, so ist dann am vergangenen Wochenende ein Erstligaspiel in den Zweitliga-Stadion in Leganés gestiegen. Das hat Raio dann auch mit 3-0 verdient gegen Atletico gewonnen. Auch irre. Aber ja, viel, viel Chaos und eigentlich katastrophale Lage um den Klub, der eigentlich schon nicht mal Europa-Pokal-Lizenz haben dürfte. Aber Erstligalizenz hatte ich mich schon auch gewundert, dass die überhaupt noch in der Liga spielen dürfen.
Aber kann man mit wenigen Worten sagen, warum Martin Preser den Verein so verkommen lässt?
Ja, das kann man sagen. Er hat natürlich primär wirtschaftliche Ziele und hofft und spekuliert so ein bisschen darauf, dass er mit der Unterstützung von Stadt und Land, Regierung, Steuergelder, da vielleicht einen Neubau starten kann. Also sein großes Ziel ist mehr aus RAIO rauszupressen, als irgendwie nur mit diesen, was sind es, 15.000 Ministadion. Es gab da zwar jetzt auch schon mal einen Entwurf von einem Umbau, aber RAIO ist ja auch sehr, sehr, das Stadion ist ja auch sehr engen Raum, wo hinter dem einen Tor ist ja gar keine Tribüne, weil da die Hochhäuser stehen. Also er versucht irgendwie ein bisschen wie beim FC Valencia. Peter Lieben, der hat es jetzt schlussendlich hinbekommen, durch den Druck mit der WM 2030, den Valencia, die Valencia sonst verpasst hätte, dass dort dann sich Stadt und Land eingemischt haben und gesagt, komm, jetzt gib mal mal ein paar Steuergelder in den Umbau des Nürburgringes, dort hat es geklappt. Und jetzt hier Martin Preser hofft so ein bisschen auf das Gleiche, dass da eben irgendwann mit staatlicher Hilfe dann irgendwie einen Umbau oder vielleicht sogar einen Neubau bekommt, weil auch da jetzt das Thema mit Umverlegung nach Leganes. Das war natürlich den Fanzen Dorn im Auge und auch die vielen Dauerkarteninhaber, ich glaube, das sind so 11.000, 12.000 rum, die haben das Spiel boykottiert, weil sie eben nicht gute Bilder haben wollten, im Sinne von, Leganes kriegen sie ja auch voll und warum spielen sie nicht öfter da so in der Martin Preser-Denke, sondern da sind, wie gesagt, große Proteste. Und vorhin hatte Jakob schon den Begriff dimision gebracht, das hört man auch in Spanien oft, also dimision ist so die Rücktrittsforderung, bei bei Rallo ist es mittlerweile der Begriff inhabilitation, also dass man ihm die Rechte abnimmt, dass man ihm das Recht abnimmt, den Club weiter zuführen. Enteignung, genau.
Sauber, wir müssen mehr über Enteignung sprechen, Leute. Stark, da war ich richtig auf.
Später habe ich noch so ein Karls Club, da fällt der Begriff auch hier und da mal.
Lass uns zum Fußball anfangen und dann aber ganz, ganz schnell bei großen Konzernen und Milliardären weitermachen.
Grüße an Bonovia. Und was wir sonst noch so haben.
Unter anderem. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Ich freue mich jetzt schon auf die Kommentare. Okay, also aber schön, dass wir ein neues Kapitel haben in der Endlossage. Mit Investoren, die Premier League einholen, auch bei Rallo. Ein Erfolgsmodell, Sondersgleichen. Einfach toll, das Schicksal eines ganzen Clubs in die Hand eines einzelnen Menschen zu legen. Danke dir, lieber Nils. Jakob, wenn du magst, dann darfst du auch direkt weitermachen. Was hast du denn in der Liga A noch für ein kurzes Thema? Ach ja, stimmt, klar, da haben wir ja auch Chaos. Das war ja eigentlich meine Übung. Deswegen wollte ich ja jetzt zu dir gehen. Was macht denn Olympique Marseille so?
Ja, haben wir auch lange nicht mehr drüber gesprochen. Eigentlich ja ungewöhnlich, dass man zweimal in Folge über den das gleiche Team spricht. Aber jetzt hat Marseille sich das, glaube ich, sehr zu Herzen genommen, dass sie hier in der Liga Tour Dauergast sein wollen. Und wir hatten ja in der letzten Woche oder vor zwei Wochen über die sportlichen Missstände gesprochen. Und das man kann, glaube ich, zu Recht behaupten, dass das jetzt ein wenig eskaliert ist in den letzten Wochen. Denn es gab dann ja zuerst die Niederlage im Le Classique 0 zu 5. Also wirklich peinlich die höchste Niederlage, die Marseille jemals gegen Paris erlitten hat. Und angesichts der besonderen Rivalität zwischen den beiden kam das nicht so richtig gut an. Danach hat Roberto de'Servi auch gesagt, dass er hilflos, also er hat nicht explizit gesagt, er sei hilflos, aber er hat gesagt, er versteht seine Mannschaft nicht. Und das war dann eigentlich klar, okay, das kann nicht mehr lange dauern. Dann hat Marseille mitten in der Nacht von Dienstag auf Mittwoch auch eine Pressebeteilung rausgegeben, dass de'Servi nicht mit länger Trainer sein soll. Es war angeblich eine einvernehmliche Trennung. Allerdings ist das dann ja meistens auch ein bisschen Wortglauberei. Damit war das Ganze aber längst noch nicht ausgestanden. Man hat dann erst mit Jacques Abaddonado aus innerhalb des Vereins eine Interims-Lösung gefunden. Vor dem Spiel am Wochenende gegen Straßburg gab es dann aber auch schon Proteste von den Fans, die de'Servi so ein bisschen als Bauernopfer gesehen haben. Die Proteste richteten sich vor allem gegen Präsident Pablo Longoria und auch den Eigentümer Frank McCord. Der wurde sehr blumig bezeichnet als der Kapitän eines Geisterschiffes, das niemals die andere Seite des Ozeans erreichen würde.
Und es ist Christian Ilzer irgendwie Kapo bei den Ultras von Marseille, ist ja fantastisch.
Ja, habe ich mir auch gedacht. Und genau dann, also gegen diese beiden gab es den Protesten, ein bisschen kurios. 15 Minuten lang haben die Ultras auch das Spiel boykottiert, sind dann erst auf die Ränge geströmt. Just als sie ins Stadion kamen, ging Marseille in Führung. Dann sah es eigentlich auch so aus, als würde zumindest sportlich so ein bisschen ein Befreiungsschlag erfolgen. Dann führte man 2-0, hat sich dann aber erneut in der Nachspielzeit noch den Ausgleich gefangen, so den Sieg verspielt. Ist jetzt das siebte Gegentor in dieser Saison, was Marseille in der Nachspielzeit der zweiten Halbzeit gefangen hat und damit noch Punkte verspielt hat. Aber das eigentliche Theater ging dann danach weiter, denn es war dann nicht Pablo Longoria oder Frank McCourt, die zuerst Konsequenzen gezogen haben, sondern Sportdirektor Mehdi Benassia hat mehrmals versucht, zurückzutreten, muss man wohl sagen. Denn er hat seinen Rücktritt eingereicht, wohl auch mehrmals. Er hat das dann auch öffentlich bestätigt, dass er wirklich zurücktreten möchte. Es sah dann auch erst so aus, als wäre das dann tatsächlich der Fall. Und dann kam jetzt aber im Laufe dieser Woche die Wende, weil Frank McCourt, der Eigentümer, sich explizit darum bemüht haben soll, dass Benassia bleibt als Sportdirektor, zumindest bis zum Ende der Saison. Und dann hat er sich auch weich klopfen lassen. Oder es wird auch spekuliert, dass es reine Taktik war von Benassia, ein sehr gelungenes Machtspiel. Denn er hat viele von seinen Vertrauten auch überall im Verein installiert. Er ist also eigentlich auch schon so der heimliche starke Mann gewesen. Und jetzt ist er auch seit ein paar Tagen dann wohl wirklich der starke Mann. Denn gleichzeitig hat Frank McCourt auch gesagt, dass Pablo Longoria, also der Präsident, eigentlich nur noch repräsentative Aufgaben haben soll. Also da hat dann sozusagen ein Machtwechsel stattgefunden. Benassia ist jetzt zumindest bis zum Sommer der starke Mann. Denn was danach ist, ist auch unklar. Er ist also auch damit beauftragt gewesen, jetzt einen neuen Trainer zu finden. Gleichzeitig soll Pablo Longoria jetzt eigentlich auch zurücktreten wollen, was allerdings auch nicht im Sinne von Marseille sein kann. Denn mit ihm haben sie einen Sitz im Liga-Verband. Und diesen Sitz im Liga-Verband würden sie verlieren, wenn Pablo Longoria zurücktritt. Denn das ist an eine Person gebunden und nicht an den Verein. Und ein Nachfolger muss mindestens ein Jahr im Amt gewesen sein, um kandidieren zu können. Das heißt, dann würde Marseille diese wichtige Machtposition innerhalb der Liga verlieren. Also wird das jetzt auch nochmal spannend, wie sich das da entwickelt und hinzieht. Und was aber jetzt erfolgt ist, gestern Abend hat Marseille dann bekannt gegeben, dass sie einen neuen Trainer gefunden haben mit Habib Bey. Ja, ist jetzt nicht so eine sonderlich inspirierende Lösung, finde ich zumindest. Der ist ja vor wenigen Tagen, inzwischen sind es zwei Wochen, in bei Startrennen entlassen worden. Hat allerdings als Spieler auch eine Geschichte bei Marseille. Also hat lange da gespielt, war auch Kapitän des Teams. Kennt also sozusagen den Verein zumindest. War jetzt bei Startrennen auch nicht unerfolgreich. Allerdings, ja, ich glaube nicht, dass der so jetzt bei den Fans als absolute Traumlösung ankommen wird zuerst. Er hat natürlich, kann er die Fans sicherlich überzeugen mit sportlichem Erfolg. Aber wo so ein bisschen ich auch schon wieder Potenzial für Unruhe sehe, dass er bei Startrennen auch vor allem nicht wegen seiner sportlichen Erfolglosigkeit, sondern wegen Konflikten mit der Kabine entlassen wurde, weil er sich wohl mit den erfahrenen Spielern oft gezofft hat. Also Brice Samba, der Torwart, wurde von ihm aussortiert. Andere Spieler wie Seco Fofana oder andere Führungsspieler sind auch gegangen dann im Winter, weil sie mit ihm überhaupt nicht zurechtgekommen sind. Und dass er jetzt eine Kabine mit noch viel mehr größeren Charakteren führen soll, klingt jetzt zumindest nicht auf den ersten Blick plausibel. Und generell muss man auch sagen, dass die Trainerwechsel jetzt auch in dieser Saison in Ligue 1 überhaupt nicht funktioniert haben. Es hat tatsächlich kein einziger neuer Trainer bisher, zumindest was den Tabellenplatz angeht, eine Verbesserung herbeiführen können, was, glaube ich, eine durchaus bemerkenswerte Statistik ist. Wir hatten das ja vorhin bei Monaco schon gesagt. Bei Nantes gab es einen Trainerwechsel kurz vor Weihnachten. Luiz Castro weg, Ahmed Kantari da. Die sind weiterhin 17. Da sind sogar eher noch schlechter geworden. Bei Nizza gab es ja eine Trainerentlassung von Frank Aas, der jetzt übrigens Nachfolger von Abib Bey bei Start rennen wird. Also da auch eine schöne Rotation innerhalb der Liga. Da ist mit Claude Puel ein alter Bekannter wieder zurück, der allerdings auch eher vielleicht zumindest mal wieder gewonnen. Aber Nizza ist trotzdem weiter abgerutscht in der Tabelle. Bei Metz gab es noch einen Trainerwechsel. Die sind aber weiterhin relativ chancenlos 18er. Also bisher bringen die Trainerwechsel auch nichts. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt bei Marseille vielleicht anders sein wird. Kurzfristiges Ziel ist natürlich jetzt erstmal noch unter die ersten drei zu kommen und damit dann die direkte Champions League Qualifikation zu holen und sicherlich nicht zu vernachlässigen, den Pokal zu gewinnen. Denn da ist Marseille ja zumindest noch im Rennen.
Und PSG schon draußen. Also Marseille, auf gar keinen Fall werden wir dieses Saison beenden können, in der Ligatour, ohne noch mal über Olympique zu sprechen. Deswegen lassen wir es dabei bewenden. Und ehrlich gesagt, mir reicht es jetzt mit den Negativgeschichten. Ich will endlich mal über ein Team sprechen, das zwar im Abstiegskampf hängt, das aber gerade Anzeichen von Leben zeigt, das eben zeigt, vielleicht geht es da unten raus. Und Uli, damit sind wir bei West Ham gelandet. Und das hätte man vor vier, fünf Spieltagen nicht unbedingt gedacht.
Ja, stimmt. Scheint so zu sein, als würde Nuno Spirito Santo immer seine halbe Saison brauchen, um irgendwo anzukommen. Das ist auch diesmal wieder der Fall gewesen. Was im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Tatsache so ist, weil er jemand zu sein scheint, der vor allen Dingen die Menschen hinter den Spielern mitzunehmen scheint. Und das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es ein gutes halbes Jahr dauert, dass er dann einfach mal einen gewissen Zugang bekommt zu denen. Neben ein paar Minianpassungen, die er vorgenommen hat, die er aber auch fairerweise schon vor einem halben Jahr probiert hat, die da nicht funktioniert haben, die aber jetzt langsam, aber sicher minimal fruchten. Das ist die eine Wahrheit und die andere ist, dass der Rest auch nicht richtig vom Fleck wegkommt. Führt dazu im Übrigen, das ist jetzt so mein Take. Ich glaube, der Absteiger, mal abgesehen davon, dass es punktetechnisch auch im Moment so zu sein scheint, wenn man alles hochrechnet, dann könnte es sein, dass der diesjährige letzte Absteiger mit fast 40 Punkten runtergeht. Aber so oder so, egal, wenn es jetzt noch erwischt von da unten. Tottenham ist ja inzwischen auch mit drin in diesem Abstiegskampf, wenn gleich sie schon noch ein bisschen Vorsprung haben. Aber sei es Tottenham, sei es Nottingham, sei es dann auch West Ham. Der dritte Absteiger ist, glaube ich, der stärkste, der jemals aus der Premier League abgestiegen ist.
Krass. Und das bringt uns ja zum übergeordneten Thema, dass wir eben noch mal kurz auf den Abstiegskampf generell gucken. Also West Ham scheint ja dann zumindest Anlass zur Hoffnung zu haben. Wem würdest du denn sagen, kannst du am ehesten gerade erwischen? Tottenham hat auch reagiert. Ist es Nottingham?
Tottenham hat reagiert. Nottingham hat schon zum vierten Mal insgesamt reagiert in der Saison, obwohl ich gar nicht groß war. Da muss es auch irgendwas Atmosphärisches geben. Featuring, Marinakis, der Besitzer da, der ist halt einfach manchmal fiebrig und reagiert ganz häufig darauf, wenn das Publikum ungehalten wird. Und die haben schon ein wenig Geduld verloren, eben auch weil West Ham angeschoben hat. Das war nämlich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht unter Sean Deitch. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt unter Vitor Pereira großartig viel besser wird, der ja auch erst in dieser Saison die Wolves verlassen hat, die ja weiterhin unten drin stehen. Also das ist auch so eine ganz eigene Sache, dass die da untereinander sich die Trainer zuschieben im Moment. Das ist ganz klassische Feuerwehrmann-Lösungen. Vitor Pereira ist never ever, wenn wir im Februar 27 noch mal Ligatour machen, da Trainern, die malz. Ich halte noch nicht mal für komplett ausgeschlossen, dass die noch mal was tun, die letzten zwei Spieltage. Weil der einfach, der will, das ist ja klar, die haben sich einen teuren Kader geleistet. Die müssen auch drin bleiben bei Nottingham. Ansonsten fällt der Verein vielleicht sogar komplett und final auseinander. Deswegen müssen die mit aller Macht da irgendwie drin bleiben. Die fand ich aber gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich. Und die haben natürlich einfach, wenn du den Kader schaust, einfach eine wahnsinnige Qualität da drin, die West Ham auch zum Teil hat, aber halt nur zum Teil. Also der Kader ist schon etwas zerrupfter als bei Nottingham. Und Tottenham ist vermutlich halt minimal zu gut dafür, als dass die nochmal so richtig mit reingeraten würden. Das Witzige ist ja das, dass also die Wolves, die sind ja schon eigentlich seit immer, die haben ja gar nicht gewonnen eine ganze Zeit lang. Die sind eigentlich schon seit immer weg. Die haben jetzt zum Beispiel gestern Abend Arsenal einen Punkt, oder zwei Punkte sogar geklaut, im wahrsten Sinne. Das heißt, da entscheiden sie fleißig mit, sind aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich ab vom Schuss. Und bei Burnley ist es so, auch der Punkt, der Abstand, ist natürlich einfach wahnsinnig gering. Und sie spielen bestenfalls unentschieden, aber gewinnen nicht, weil da, glaube ich, die individuelle Qualität einfach nicht da ist. Aber da gibt es immer mal auch so Wochen, wo ich denke, Mensch, vielleicht sind sie doch wieder da. Und die haben sich auch gar nicht so schlecht verstärkt, noch mal im Winter, aber vermutlich wird es trotzdem nicht reichen. Ja, also ist es nicht ganz leicht zu sagen, im Moment wirkt Nottingham sehr viel zerfahrener als West Ham. Das ist so die aktuelle Bestandsaufnahme. Das mag sich natürlich auch schnell wieder ändern. Weil, muss man ja auch sagen, minus dieser einen Saison, die es jetzt letztes Jahr gab bei Nottingham, wo es einfach in die andere Richtung dynamisch lief, nämlich, dass alles einfach plötzlich funktioniert hat, haben sie das ja schon zweimal in Folge davor gemacht. Und da war jeweils das Publikum der absolute Gamechanger, weil die Stimmung trotzdem derart positiv war, weil sie im Grunde mit nichts anderem gerechnet haben. Es kann schon sein, dass sich dieser Effekt auch wieder einstellt, wie der Pereira es nicht schlecht in Sachen Umfeldversicht gewinnen.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn ein Punkte diesmal nicht vor Abstieg schützen, wer weiß, ob wir da vielleicht dann doch nochmal über Leeds, doch nochmal über Brighton sprechen, hatten wir ja auch zuletzt mit hier in der Ligatour.
Genau, also Leeds nehme ich fast schon gar nicht mehr mit rein, weil das Komplizierteste, was die zu erledigen hatten, war eigentlich so von Anfang Dezember bis Ende Januar. Ich hätte nie damit gerechnet, dass Daniel Fakir noch im Amt ist. Niemals. Also mir war klar, wir haben auch immer so im Podcast gesagt, der wird, wenn es hochkommt, darf er noch Weihnachten machen, weil die wollten den da eh nie haben. Und mit dem Programm kann der eigentlich nur verlieren. Und der ist für jeden einzelnen Gegner ein schwieriges Spiel im Moment, sodass ich Leads fast schon, also die sind bei mir so fast schon weg, weil die sind so funktionell. Das ist ja ganz oft so, dass wenn Teams wie Nottingham etwas ungefragt da unten reinkommen, dann haben sie Schwierigkeiten zu adaptieren. Und die machen ja auch noch diesen Spagat. Das ist ja das Seltsame. Weil auf der einen Seite kämpfen sie ums blanke Überleben, auf der anderen Seite redet Marinakis schon auch intern wohl darüber, dass sie den Europapokal gewinnen wollen, in dem sie ja noch vertreten sind. Das heißt, da sind sie auch unter Jean Deitsch vor allen Dingen richtig gut gewesen. Es sah lange Zeit noch danach aus, als würden sie sich direkt qualifizieren können und eben nicht in die Zwischenrunde müssen. Was natürlich bitter ist für einen englischen Verein, wenn er jetzt noch sozusagen dann Donnerstag, Donnerstag im Einsatz ist. Und das ist auf der anderen Seite bei Lied. Die haben sich von Anfang an nichts vorgemacht, dass es ums nackte Überleben gehen wird. Und das merkt man denen an. Und da hat Daniel Fahke, gerade auch, das hätte ich ihm niemals zugetraut nach Gladbacher Zeiten, eine richtig wehrhafte Defensive, also Umschalten von der Offensive in die Defensive, eingebaut. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das gibt bei ihm, aber es ist sogar soweit gehe ich, wenn das klappt. Einer der Favoriten Coach of the Year.
Ha, krass.
Okay, da müssen wir demnächst nochmal länger drüber sprechen. Aber Uli, auch du musst jetzt los. Ich habe, wenn ich es richtig ergoogelt habe, wir haben uns in einer kurzen Pause gerade gefragt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, welches Klassikstück das ist, wo nacheinander alle Instrumente aufhören zu spielen. Und das auch damals so als mögliche Rebellion gegen den damaligen Fürsten gesehen wurde. Es müsste die Overtüre zum Freischütz gewesen sein. Die spielen wir jetzt nach und verabschieden auch Uli. Schöner wurdest du noch nie verabschiedet, Uli. Gibst du. Danke dir für deine Zeit.
Mein Lieber, vielen Dank.
Auch ein. Bis bald. So, und wir machen weiter. Daniel, du hast gefühlt drei Stunden schon nichts mehr sagen dürfen. Es tut mir leid. Ich musste gerade richtig überlegen, wer ist jetzt überhaupt noch dran? Ja, Daniel, du auf jeden Fall. Was haben wir denn noch so in der Ehredivise oder in den Niederlanden generell zu besprechen?
Genau. Und im Gegensatz zu den Instrumenten, die sich verabschieden könnten, in den Niederlanden bald Dinge hinzukommen, wie Beleidigungen und dann Stern. Also es ist sehr interessant, was gerade passiert. Also Hintergrund ist in den Niederlanden, gibt es keine offene Pyramidensysteme in der Liga. Das heißt, wir haben die erste Liga, wir haben die zweite, das ist die sogenannte Kölken Kampioen Divisi, ein furchtbarer Sponsor, ist aber auch schon Kult geworden. Es stinkt zwar nicht nach Rhin, wie in Spanien, aber es ist auch eine Art von Kult, die KKD, die Kölken Kampioen Divisi. Und aus der kann man fast nicht absteigen. Es gibt eine Ausnahme für die U23-Teams, das sind die Young-Teams, Young Ajax, Young PSV. Die können unter Umständen absteigen in Ausnahmefällen. Aber eigentlich ist das nur ein System. Nach der 2. Liga kommt dann die 3. Liga, die heißt da 2. Divisi. Und da ist das Problem, was viele Amateur-Clubs haben, dass sie mittlerweile eigentlich strukturell und auch sportlich schon das Niveau sehr gesteigert haben in den letzten Jahren. Und die sind eigentlich durchaus vergleichbar mit einigen Zweitligisten, können aber trotzdem wissenschaftlich aufsteigen. Deshalb ein typisches geschlossenes System, was in den letzten Jahren immer mehr für Missstände gesorgt hat. Und vor einer Woche ungefähr kamen dann einige Amateur-Clubs zum Verband, KNVB, und haben ihr Leid geklagt und sich dafür aufgesprochen, dass man dieses System wieder öffnet. Und die Chancen dafür stehen auch ganz gut. Also man hat das damals eingeführt, weil eben die Differenz und die Kluft zwischen Amateur-Teams und Profi-Teams sehr, recht groß war. Also wir reden auch wirklich von so Ackerplätzen. Und da ist dann, war wirklich nicht viel da. Und das hat sich eben verändert. Und viele fühlen sich von den Amateur-Clubs bereit, eben diesen Schritt zu gehen, bei einem Aufstieg, also bei dem möglichen Aufstieg, dann eben auch wirklich aufzusteigen. Und nicht wie jetzt ein Blut draussen bekommen. Und das nette Worte. Und das könnte in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren sogar schon passieren, heißt es da. Und ich halte es auch für sehr wahrscheinlich und realistisch, als das klappt. Und dann können tolle Vereine wie The Treffers und die Kosakken Boys können dann in den Profifußball aufsteigen. Und das würde ich zum anderen nehmen, mal diese schöne 2. Liga, diese KKLD, noch mal ein bisschen näher zu erklären. Weil da gibt es ein, zwei Sachen, die, glaube ich, sehr bemerkenswert sind. Und es ist vor allem die Regelung des Aufstiegs zwischen ihrer Division und der 2. Liga. Das ist herausragend. Also es fängt relativ simpel an. Meister und Bielsten müssen aufsteigen. Das ist recht easy in ihrer Division. Und dann gibt es die Playoffs. Und diese Playoffs bestreiten 6 weitere Teams aus der 2. Liga. Es gibt insgesamt 20 Vereine. Und trotzdem ist es eine Ansage mit 6 weiteren neben den ersten beiden, dass die mitspielen dürfen um diesen Aufstieg. Und die werden aber nicht nur über das Liga qualifiziert, sondern es gibt 38 Spieltage und diese werden in 4 Perioden aufgeteilt. Spieltag 1 bis 10, Spieltag 11 bis 19 und so weiter. Also die ungefähr so alle neun oder vier Spieltage haben. Und es gibt dann vier Periodenmeister. Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt, wenn die mir zum Beispiel mal Dortrecht, die sind gerade auf Platz 6 der Tabelle, wenn die jetzt an Spieltag 10 bis 11 bis 19 alles gewinnen, die Spiele, dann haben die diese Periode gewonnen und bekommen damit neben so einem schönen Pokal, so einem Schild auch das Zicke für die Playoffs. Daraus entsteht natürlich die Möglichkeit, dass Dortrecht sonst nichts gewinnt. Die können komplett miserabel in die Saison gestartet sein. Die können dann irgendwie acht Spieltage in Folge gewinnen, weil vielleicht die Form gut ist, weil vielleicht die Gegner nominell schwächer sind, weil sie nicht gegen die ersten müssen und so. Können dann gewinnen, können dann nach wie der alles verlieren und könnten dann rein theoretisch als Tabellen 15. um den Aufstieg spielen. Das ist möglich. Und das ist natürlich ein System. Es ist wahnsinnig, wenn man sich überlegt, man wird dann eventuell dafür belohnt, dass man von 38 Spieltagen bei 9 gewonnen hat oder so. Aber so ist es. Und dann hat man diese vier Periodenmeister. Dann kommen noch zwei Vereine hinzu, die dann an der Endtabelle, nach denen die besten sind, neben den Periodenmeistern und den beiden Deckaufsteigern. Und die spielen dann mit dem Rückspiel in einem KO-Turnier aus, wer dann letztendlich gegen den 16. Eredivisie in der eigenen Kollegation spielen darf. Das heißt, die fangen auch, glaube ich, schon irgendwie Ende März, Anfang April mit diesen Sachen an. Weil du brauchst ja auch Zeit dafür, wenn du so von dir veranstaltest. Und es gibt auch ein bisschen Kritik aus der Eredivisie bzw. von der zweiten Liga an der Eredivisie. Früher war es so, vor ein paar Jahren, dass der Tabellensechzehnte schon früher in dieses Turnier eingestiegen ist. Ich glaube, schon im Halbfinale musste er dann ran und dann eben auch noch mal im Finale. Und seit der aktuellen Saison ist es so, dass der Tabellensechzehnte der ersten Liga auch erst im Finale dann dazugeschaltet wird. Das hat quasi wie in Deutschland wirklich nur ein Hin- und Hinsichtsspiel an der Relegation. Und das heißt, es macht es für die Tabellensechze für den ersten Ligisten dann noch mal einfacher, die Klasse über die Relegation zu halten, als das noch vor ein paar Jahren war. Das hat man vor allem gemacht, weil der Kalender schon so aufgebläht war, als man da gesagt hat, ihr kriegt ein Hin- und Hinsichtsspiel weniger. Und ja, so ist die Situation in der 2. Liga mit diesem Playoff. Das hat natürlich Vor- und Nachteile. Aber ich glaube, dass es für mich persönlich die Nachteile überwiegt, wenn man überlegt, da werden Vereine belohnt für 8 gute Spiele in Folge. Und das war es. Zumal man ja auch sagen muss, dadurch, dass es ja noch ein größeres System ist, hast du auch ganz oft das Problem, dass dann gesagt wird, okay, jetzt haben wir 8, 9 Spiele in Folge gewonnen. Wozu jetzt noch großartig anstrengen? Wir sind nicht irgendwie im Bereich, dass wir Meister, Höchstsemester werden können. Absteigen geht ja nicht. Also schwimmen wir mal irgendwie ein halbes Jahr zu Spielern, gucken zu, dass sich da keiner verletzt, oder probieren wir was aus, oder mal gucken. Und können dann bei den Rehausspielen, die aber aufsteigen, theoretisch.
Also ich habe drei Dinge dazu zu sagen. Erstmal, danke, dass du das erklärt hast, weil neulich ist bei Blue Sky in so einem internationalen What's Hot Feed genau das an mir vorbeigeflogen. Und ich habe gar nichts verstanden. Und dachte mir, was ist das überhaupt? Was soll das? Ich verstehe es nicht. Periodenmeister, war auch auf niederländisch. Also ich war auch quasi, es gab eine Sprachbarriere. Okay, jetzt weiß ich, worum es ging. Und das ist deswegen an mir vorbeigeflogen, weil die jetzt nämlich ihren letzten Spieltag haben. Und dann geht es nämlich ja los. Also jetzt 20. Februar. Und dann, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, startet dann eben dieses Playoff-System Platz zwei. Oder das zweite, was ich sagen will. Es ist ganz eindeutig, dass sich die Niederlande das belgische System angeguckt hat und gesehen hat, wie kompliziert das ist und sich gedacht hat, hold my beer, my fruchtversetztes Bier. Und das haben sie gemacht. Und das dritte ist, es gilt die alte Faustregel. Wenn ein Modus so kompliziert ist, dass er ein komplettes Ligatour-Segment braucht, um erklärt zu werden, dann ist es ein schlechter Modus. Dann überwiegen die Nachteile.
Vielleicht noch ein Ding. Ich habe auch nicht zufällig dort recht genommen als Beispiel, weil es ist gerade die dritte Periode, also noch so zehn Spieltage insgesamt. Spielen sie noch, bevor dann die Sablieraufsachen losgehen. Dort recht ist zum Beispiel gerade auf Platz 6. Platz 6 sind irgendwie 13 Punkte hinter Platz 2. Also Direktaufstieg wird dann doch ein bisschen schwierig werden. Die sind aber auf einem guten Weg, die aktuell dritte Periode, die noch, glaube ich, ein, zwei Spieltage geht, zu gewinnen.
Ah, dann geht die nur noch ein Spieltag. Ich bin hier auf die offiziellen Liga-Seite und alles ist auf niederländisch. Also Entschuldigung, ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Es ist aber auch schwierig erklärt. Ich habe mir das auch nochmal so vorbeigeneu angeschaut. Es ist kompliziert. Und dort recht ist also jetzt in der dritten Periode dabei, die zu gewinnen. Da habe ich innerhalb dieser Periodentabelle auch schon mehr Punkte Vorsprung. Sind aber in der Gesamt-Tabelle nur auf Platz 6 haben 3 Punkte oder 4 Punkte vor Fanlo auf 11. Das heißt, die Chancen stehen gut, dass das FC Dortrecht genauso ein Fall wird. Dass sie jetzt eine gute Phase haben, weil die Gegner vielleicht ein bisschen flächer sind nominell oder die Form dann gut ist. Die am Ende aber vermutlich durchaus auf 11, 12 landen könnten. Also im kompletten Niemandsland. Aber Ticket bekommen, das ist ein Kampf der Playoffs.
Das ist wahrscheinlich gut.
Okay, haben wir wieder was dazugelernt. Dann schauen wir noch ein letztes Mal nach Spanien. Irgendwie liegt das an den kurzen Pausen, die wir hatten zwischen den Verabschiedungen. Aber irgendwie wirkt das heute wie eine mehrstündige Aufnahme. Nils, ich hoffe, du bist noch bei Geistiger Frische.
Ich bin doch da. Der Hunger kommt langsam, aber alles okay. Das Thema muss ich auf jeden Fall auch noch loswerden. Eben hatte ich schon Radio-Chaos-Lupen. Jetzt kommt natürlich auch wieder ein Chaos-Club, wo auch immer der Eigentümer in Kritik steht. Redet man gleich auch noch drüber. Aber jetzt am Wochenende war der FC Sevilla gegen Alavis im Einsatz. Also es wird auch mal ein bisschen sportlich haben. 1-1 gespielt, sind weiter in der Abstiegszone. Platz 3 mit 26 Punkten, also 2 Punkte vor Mallorca auf dem ersten Abstiegsrand. Und da ist es dann in der Schlussphase zu einem Platzverweis für den Trainer gekommen. Das ist Matthias Almeida, der ist seit Saisonbeginn da. Durch Abstiegskampf überschaubar erfolgreich bisher. Und ja, jetzt kann man überlegen, dass mal der ein oder andere Trainer vielleicht auch in der Bundesliga schon mal rot gesehen hat, weil er sich vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr aufgeregt hat. Okay, dann ist er vielleicht mal ein, zwei Spiele raus. Aber jetzt müsst ihr euch alle gerne auch zu den Zuhörerinnen mal überlegen, was muss denn ein Trainer machen, um für sieben Spiele gesperrt zu werden? Die Antwort ist, ich kann es euch selber auch nicht ganz erklären, weil es geht nicht ganz heraus. Der Verband hat zwar hier und da gesagt, zwei Spiele da, ein Spiel dafür, aber es ist wirklich eine wilde Situation gewesen da, 85. Minute gegen Alaviz, wo eben so ein kleines Alavels-Foul im Mittelfeld passiert ist. Und Almeyda hat so ein bisschen so, oh man, was ist das jetzt wieder? So geht kurz in die Knie, geht zurück zur Bank. Und dann der Schiedsrichter sieht das so ein bisschen, zirkt aus der Distanz, rote Karte, also komplett unklar, wer hat jetzt rot gesehen, irgendwer vom Staff? Almeyda weiß auch nicht, ich bleibe hier sitzen, weil er hat ja nicht mit mir geredet oder so. Dann geht das Spiel so eine Minute weiter, bis der Schiedsrichter auffällt, der, dem ich gerade aus 10, 20 Metern rot gezeigt habe, der sitzt ja immer noch da. Und dann ging da die Diskussion ein bisschen los, dann ist auch ein Almeyda ein bisschen emotionaler geworden, im Sinne von, dann kam der Schiedsrichter mal entgegen, hat gesagt, hey, du hast übrigens gerade rot gesehen, Almeyda geht hin, eh, wo warst du denn, erklär's mir doch mal. Dann ist es auch ein bisschen kurze Distanz, sieht dann ein bisschen emotionaler aus, ohne dass da jetzt Beleidigungen gefallen sind oder so. Also das ist jetzt von Lippenlesern noch nicht herausgefunden worden, da hat jetzt keiner sich das Trikot drüber gezogen. Und so ist dann irgendwie die Situation auch gar nicht groß eskaliert. Wie gesagt, Almeyda war ein bisschen emotional und dann wurde er auch teilweise noch mal zurückgezogen, hat dann auch mal mit dem 4. Offiziellen geredet, bis er dann in die Kabine schlussendlich gelaufen ist. Und so summiert sich so ein bisschen diese Sperre für ihn, das unter anderem für das, er saß noch auf der Bank, ist nicht gleich in die Kabine, gibt's ein Spielsperre für generelle Proteste gegen den Schiedsrichter, gibt's zwei Spielsperre für eine respektlose Haltung gegenüber den Schiedsrichter, gibt's drei Spielsperre und dann bleibt noch ein generelles Verhalten gegen die gute Ordnung, auch noch ein Spielsperre. Und so kommen irgendwie sieben Spielsperre zusammen, wo man, wenn man sich, wie gesagt, das Spiel oder die Szene anschaut, sich wirklich denkt, hä, was ist da passiert? Also Almeyder sich vielleicht auch danach auf der PK noch entschuldigt, dass es dann, wie gesagt, ein bisschen emotionaler wurde, aber er wusste einfach nicht, worum es ging, was überhaupt er gemeint ist. Und da sieht man mal wieder das Thema, so ein bisschen dünnhäutige, vielleicht vermeintlich arrogante Schiedsrichter. In dem Fall ist es, jetzt kommt ein gefährlicher Name wieder, Josu Galic Apestegui– Apestegui– Apestegui, baskischer Name, der ist 35 Jahre alt, pfeift zum ersten Mal überhaupt in dieser Saison in La Liga. Also er hat jetzt seine ersten 13 La Liga-Spiele auch da. Merkt man vielleicht so ein bisschen, ah, wärst du mal beim Zeigen der roten Karte vielleicht schon eher klarer hingegangen und hättest dich nicht ganz so dünnhäutig präsentiert. Also da ist das schon mal, wie gesagt, eine wilde Szene, wenn man denkt, oh, eine Siebenspiele-Sperre für einen Trainer, der muss ja richtig einen rausgehauen haben. Nö, ist alles irgendwie nicht passiert, wenn es am Ende dann ein, zwei, vielleicht sogar drei Spiele-Sperre gewesen wären. Okay, aber sieben, der Klub will natürlich dagegen vorgehen, steht hinter dem Trainer, logisch. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall mal wieder erwähnenswert.
Und sportlich gesehen, glaubst du, das könnte Sevilla wirklich erwischen? Weil wir alle kennen natürlich Sevilla durch die tausende Europa League-Siege eher so als erfolgreiches Team.
Ja, das ist jetzt die letzten Jahre ein ziemlicher Downfall gewesen. Auch sportliche wie wirtschaftliche Situationen sehr überschaubar. Ich glaube, ich hatte auch mal im Rasenfunk erzählt, dass die beim La Liga Salary Cap der Gehaltsübergrenze mal nur 250.000 Euro zur Verfügung hatten. Das ist mittlerweile natürlich ein bisschen gewachsen, weil so ein paar Großverdiener, wie auch mal ein Rakitic und so weiter, dann noch los geworden sind, aber trotzdem immer noch. Ich glaube, es gibt aktuell Nettoverschuldung, liegt bei 88 Millionen, dann haben sie noch Kredite aufgenommen von 170 Millionen Euro. Das ist jetzt alles mehr und mehr bekannt geworden, weil jetzt ist gerade im Umlauf, dass es einen bekannten Namen gibt, der den Club wohl kaufen will. Und da ist er, der Mann wie ein Rambock. Da ist er, der Ramos. Der will jetzt wahrscheinlich seinen Ex-Club kaufen. Also Sergio Ramos hat da jetzt wohl verschiedene Investoren zusammengetrommelt mit so einer Investorengruppe 511 Capital, um den FC Sevilla zumindest ein Angebot zu unterbreiten. Da wird es jetzt auch juristisch und finanziell schwierig. Es gibt einen LUI, ein Letter of Interest, also eine Absichtserklärung zu kaufen. Jetzt müssen natürlich die Bücher studiert werden. Da sind die Wirtschaftsprüfer vom KPMG wohl dabei, genau zu schauen, wie die Verbindlichkeiten aussehen, welche Gehälter noch ausstehen, welche noch gezahlt werden und alles so mit dem drohenden Abstieg. Aber das ist durchaus eine Option, dass wirklich Sergio Ramos da den Club zumindest übernimmt. Und auch der bisherige Präsident, Jose Maria del Nido Carrasco, den hatte ich auch schon mal erwähnt. Da gibt es auch schon ein paar Juve der Ja-Rufe. Oder man sieht viele Profilbilder im Sinne von Junior. Er ist der Sohn von Ex-Präsidenten, dass der, dem der Rücktritt nahegelegt wird von vielen Fans. Viele Protestaktionen da auch. Dass der offen dafür wäre oder zu viel, hätte er damit dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht zu entscheiden. Aber ja, sportliche Situation ist große Krise, weil der Club sich gerade so irgendwie jetzt seit Jahren über Wasser halten kann. Aber im Endeffekt sind irgendwie hast du 10, 11 Clubs in der Liga, die irgendwie in der Abstiegszone feststecken, wo jeder mal jeden den Punkt abnimmt. Keiner kann sich so richtig festsetzen, außer vielleicht kreativistische, die sich da jetzt raus befreit haben. Dank Matarazzo. Aber gibt mal wieder nicht so viele schöne Storys rund um Sevilla, auch wenn das jetzt rund um Almeida irgendwie sehr drüber und verdient ist.
Aber wirklich. Und 511 Capital. Ich habe das nochmal ganz schnell jetzt versucht, nebenher nachzugucken, weil mir der Name bekannt vorkam. Die versuchen gerade in Fußball reinzukommen. Noch nicht bei großen Teams, bei Espanol waren sie auch im Gespräch. Ich glaube, da ist es mir über den Weg gelaufen. Und sie haben auch schon bei einem ungerischen und einem brasilianischen Verein angeklopft. Und zum Teil sind sie da auch schon mit Minderheitsbeteiligung mit dabei. Das ist so der klassische Fall von, haben Investmentgeld zusammengeholt, so Venture-Capital-mäßig, und wollen jetzt noch irgendwie versuchen, ein Multiclub-Ding aufzuziehen, weil so langsam gibt es ja keine Vereine mehr, die man da reinholen kann. Deswegen, ja.
Da ist ja der FC Sevilla eigentlich schon so halb drin, aber da kennen jetzt viele, wie heißen sie, 777-Partners von Hertha BSC, die es ja dann jetzt doch irgendwie nicht mehr richtig gibt. Die sind eigentlich, oder da gehört noch der FC Sevilla hin, aber das ist dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein totes Investment mittlerweile. Wie gesagt, das könnte gut passieren, dass wirklich Sergio Ramos da mit verschiedenen Investoren-Kumpels sich da einkäuft, aber das wird sich natürlich noch ein paar Wochen ziehen, wenn jetzt Wirtschaftsprüfer da dabei sind. Wenn es dann eh darum geht, ja, der Abstieg ist jetzt realistisch, dann wenn du dann nächste Saison nur noch die Hälfte am Einnahmen hast, wird das noch mal schwieriger oder vielleicht einfacher mit der Übernahme, aber da bin ich dann jetzt auch überfragt.
Ja, und das Ganze mit Triple Seven, das ist jetzt nochmal ein eigenes Thema, weil da wurden ja schon Teile der Beteiligung weiterverkauft, Cap A oder wie auch immer die heißen, die sitzen jetzt auch bei Hertha mit drin und so weiter. Du wirst diese Investoren nicht mehr los. Das ist die Bralle von der Geschichte. Liebe Kinder da draußen und liebe Erwachsenen, legt euch nicht mit Investoren ins Bett, selbst wenn ihr den einen rausgekickt bekommt, legt sich ein anderer hin. Und der hat seine ganz eigenen Interessen. Also das ist einfach gut. Aber unsere Meinung ist da eh klar. Jakob, du bist noch ein letztes Mal dran. Ich bin hier schon völlig verwirrt. Inzwischen, worüber wollen wir denn bei dir noch sprechen? Ich glaube, es geht ja auch um Abstiegskampf.
Ja, aber tatsächlich eine positivere Geschichte aus dem Abstiegskampf, denn es ist ein Team, was tatsächlich nicht den Klassen, der halt schon sicher hat, aber sich zumindest auf einem guten Weg dahin befindet und bei dem man das jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten konnte vor der Saison. Und das ist AC Le Havre. Die sind auch einer der kleineren Vereine in Frankreich. Wir hatten es jetzt schon häufiger, haben auch im Sommer keinen einzigen Cent für neue– also zumindest keine Ablösen für neue Spieler ausgegeben, sondern ausschließlich ablösefreie Spieler geholt und Spieler geliehen und sind damit aber sehr erfolgreich. Wir stehen jetzt auf Platz 13, 26 Punkte haben neun Punkte Vorsprung schon auf den Relegationsabstiegsplatz. Wir haben jetzt auch zuletzt zwei wichtige Siege eingefahren, zweimal 2 zu 1, besonders jetzt der letzte Sieg auch gegen Toulouse bemerkenswert, weil schon in der ersten Minute der Kapitän und Innenverteidiger Aruna Sangante glatt rot gesehen hat für ein hartes Einsteigen. Also da haben sie wirklich das ganze Spiel in Unterzahl gespielt und trotzdem das Spiel gewonnen. Und ja, maßgeblich dafür verantwortlich ist zum Beispiel ist der Trainer Didier Degas, der hat aus La Afri wirklich ein super unangenehm zu bespielendes Team gemacht. Also die haben die viertbeste Abwehr in der Ligue 1, nur Lens, Lyon und PSG und dann noch Toulouse, die fünftbeste Abwehr. Also die Top 3 und Toulouse haben weniger Gegentore kassiert als La Afri. Und sie haben auch nur einmal mehr als drei Gegentore kassiert, nur dreimal ein Spiel mit mehr als einem Tor. Unterschied verloren, also sie sind immer drin in den Spielen. Erinnert einen vielleicht so ein bisschen an St. Pauli in der letzten Saison. Die Referenz kann ich mir natürlich nicht entgehen lassen, sagen wir es mal so. Sie schießen auch nicht so viele Tore, haben nur 20 Tore geschossen, haben damit den zweitschlechtesten Sturm in der Liga. Das reicht aber. Im Sturm bemerkenswert finde ich Isa Soumaré. Der ist auch so ein Spieler, ja, würde auch super gut zu St. Pauli passen. Er ist nämlich ein Stürmer, der vieles gut kann, aber vor dem Tor wahnsinnig ineffektiv ist. Aber schlechtes ist. Er hat schon zehn Expected Goals gesammelt, aber nur fünf oder sechs Tore daraus gemacht. Sechs gemacht, ja, also performt deutlich unter. Hat jetzt in den letzten beiden Spielen aber dreimal getroffen, auch die beiden Tore beim 2-1 gegen Toulouse gemacht und ist an sich ein richtig cooler Spieler, finde ich. Also kann sich super gut behaupten, haut sich in alles rein, steht in vielen Statistiken wirklich gut da und ja, performt da super, aber ja, ist halt nicht der Treffsicherste. Dann haben sie jetzt im Winter aber mit Soufian Bouffal auch noch einen alten Bekannten geholt, der jetzt auch schon ein bisschen älter ist, aber gleich zwei Vorlagen gegeben hat jetzt, seitdem er da ist, also da auch ganz gut dabei ist und hat und in der Innenverteidigung auch noch zwei interessante Spieler. Da ist nämlich zum einen Gautier Juris, der kleine Bruder von Hugo Juris. Der spielt da jetzt schon länger und jetzt in den letzten drei Spielen hat sich in den Vordergrund gespielt Stefan Sagadou, dessen Stunde schlug dann auch beim 2 zu 1 gegen Straßburg, als er sich hochschraubte im Strafraum wie sein kleiner Bruder, wie sein großer Bruder und dann sein erstes Profitor eingenickt hat. Da auf jeden Fall sich dann auch in den Vordergrund gespielt hat, also das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr positive Geschichte, zumal auch mit Abdoulaye Toure, einer der zentralen Spieler, jetzt schon länger verletzt fehlt, aber Didier Degas, der da als junger Trainer auch wirklich mit 39 ja auch noch nicht so neu im Geschäft, bei ihm auch schön, dass er aus Le Havre kommt, also da auch in der Jugend gespielt hat als Spieler, also da echt gut etabliert ist und das ist definitiv eine der positiven Geschichten in dieser Saison.
Aber wirklich, also erstmal Respekt, wie tief ihr immer in euren Ligen drin seid, das ist echt fantastisch und ich bin froh, dass das ist der jüngere Bruder von Dan Axel Sagadou ist, weil er ist ja erst 17 Jahre alt, das wäre ein bisschen, wenn er der ältere gewesen wäre, hätte ich Anschlussfragen gehabt. Okay, aber damit haben wir noch einen letzten Blick in die Niederlande zu werfen. Daniel, leider kommen wir nicht in positiver Stimmung aus dieser Sendung raus.
Leider ist es so. Es geht um Oleksandr Tsenchenko. Der ist ja von Arsenal jetzt im Februar am Metlai-Day noch gewechselt zu Ajax. Und wir waren eigentlich alle froh und mutig, dass dadurch das Problem auf den außen verteidiger Position bei Ajax ein bisschen gelöst werden kann. Und dann kam es leider so, dass er sich jetzt beim Startelf-Dibüt, also im zweiten Einsatz überhaupt erst für Ajax, sehr, sehr schlimm verletzt hat. Also, das war nach zwei, drei Minuten schon, Lack auf dem Boden und das kam jetzt raus. Er hatte eine schwere Knieoperation nötig und er fällt jetzt in der Tat bis zur neuen Saison aus. Also, er hatte dann ja insgesamt vielleicht mit der Einwechslung in dem Spiel davor 20 Minuten gespielt für seinen neuen Verein, für Ajax und ist jetzt erstmal raus. Und das ist natürlich an der Stelle vor allem eine gute Besserung, weil er sah schon sehr, sehr unschön aus auf dem Feld gegen Setat und wirft Ajax natürlich persönlich zurück. Also, er hatte ja auch noch spekuliert, auch im Grund für den Wechsel, dass er zur WM-Teilnahme ja noch kann. Also, die Ukraine kämpft ja noch um den WM-Teiltitel und da kann er nicht mit mitwirken. Und auch wenn die Ukraine das schaffen sollte, sich zu qualifizieren, wäre er ja auch raus. Insofern ist das für ihn einmal doppelt tragisch. Und aber auch für Ajax sind da verschiedene Probleme, die sich dann eröffnen. Also, der Interimstrainer Fred Krim hatte in den letzten drei Start-Ausstellungen fünf verschiedene AVs ausprobiert. Meistens aus leistungstechnischen Gründen, oft aber auch aus anderen Verletzungen oder Sperren. Das heißt, man hatte eigentlich diese konstante auf den Außen-Teil-Kosition. Und die Lücke wollte man mit Zitelgo schließen. Und auf tragische Weise geht das nun leider nicht. Man muss aber aus All-Aksicht auch festhalten, dass sie sich trotzdem, seit ich es erwähnte, schon leicht angedeutet stabilisiert haben. Also in den anderen Mannschaftsteilen hat man jetzt so ein bisschen einen Gerüst sich draus gebaut. Also Casper Dolberg im Stor, Matvek Horst auf die Bank mittlerweile verdrängt. Das habe ich so auch nicht kommen sehen zum Beginn der Saison. David Klaassen spielt jetzt wieder den Kickstar, auch nicht kaputt. Der Routinier, der spielt jetzt auch wieder eine größere Rolle. Im Mittelfeld ist er eigentlich gesetzt. Und der Mika Hrotz in der Offensive, das belgische Talent ist es eigentlich schon nicht mehr. Das ist vielleicht auch schon die Stammkraft geworden bei Ajax und auch im Fokus anderer größerer Vereine. Der macht seinen Job auch richtig gut. Und deswegen konnte er dann auch ohne Sinchenko dann 4-1 gewinnen, jetzt gegen Südtat. Und es geht so ein bisschen unter, in der Liga hat Ajax seit November nicht mehr verloren. Echt? Ja, ja. Zwischen Tränen sind so Aussätze dabei, wie diese 6-0-Klatsche im Pokal gegen AZ. Oder auch hier und da mal ein Punktverlust in der Liga, unentschieden gegen kleinere Teams, die eben dann das Spiel ein bisschen trüben. Aber die letzte Liga-Näheanlage, die war glaube ich Ende November. Und das hatte ich so auch nicht, noch nicht auf dem Schirm. Aber es zeigt eben, dass Ajax sich verbalisiert hat, auch wenn noch nicht alles so rund läuft, sage ich mal. Aber in der Stelle nochmal gute Besserung an Sinchenko.
Aber wirklich. Und dann hast du es ja tatsächlich geschafft, den Kracher jetzt an diesem Wochenende zwischen NEC Nijmegen und Ajax auch noch von der anderen Seite zu beleuchten. Du bist einfach ein gottverdammter Profi. In diesem Sinne, ich danke euch jetzt hier Anwesenden noch dreien und den beiden Abwesenden auch noch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Herzlichen Dank an Jakob Haffke, an Nils Kern, an Daniel Zander und natürlich auch an Christian Bernhard und Uli Hebel. Ich werde verlinken, wo man denen allen folgen kann. Vielen, vielen Dank für eure Zeit.
Schönen Abend noch. Gerne, gerne.
Bei Nils ist es jetzt schon Abend. Genau. Und da danke ich natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist werbe-payable und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Das haben getan Daniel, Flo2Speak, Raphael, Mirro, Seppo und Lorenz. Auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr einen Unterstützen-Button. Und da erfahrt ihr alle Informationen, wie man uns Geld zukommen lassen kann. Auch in der Video- und Podcastbeschreibung ist das der Fall. In diesem Sinne, danke für euren Support. Werdet oder bleibt gesund und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.